[Musique]
Lamia SM Lali, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bah, je
m'appelle Lamali.
Je suis franco-marocaine,
donc née en banlieu parisienne
et depuis à peu près 20 ans, je
dédiction de l'océan. Je me définirai
comme une activiste.
Euh et ma vie a changé le jour où j'ai
rencontré le capitaine Paul Watson qui
qui m'a demandé si j'étais prête à
risquer ma vie pour sauver une baleine.
Et j'avais jamais vu de baleine de ma
vie.
Mais pour moi, la réponse, elle était
évidente.
Et là, j'ai pris j'ai pris un tournant
et voilà. 20 ans plus tard, j'y suis
toujours euh à des années lumières de là
où je suis née en fait, puisque je suis
née donc dans une cité assez difficile,
loin de la mer. Euh j'ai connu l'océan
au Maroc parce que j'avais la chance
quand même d'y aller tous les étés et
c'est là que j'ai été touchée par la
force de l'océan. qui m'a montré aussi
qu'il y avait autre chose que que cette
cité dans laquelle dans laquelle
j'étais, cet univers bitumé sans sans
horizon. Et euh et c'est après, c'est en
grandissant en fait que je me suis rendu
compte que cet océan, il était en train
de mourir euh et que nous, notre espèce
en fait, on en était responsable et
qu'en plus on était lié à l'océan. Non
seulement on en vient, mais que si
l'océan meurt, on meurt tous. Et donc la
vie a fait que ben j'ai croisé la route
de quelqu'un qui m'a permis d'avoir le
sentiment aujourd'hui d'être à ma place
et d'être dans un combat bah pour lequel
je dédquelle je suis effectivement prêt
à mourir.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler écologie bien
entendu. On va parler baleine Paul
Watson, on va parler géopolitique, on va
parler aussi pourquoi la lutte et
quelles sont les motivations, quels sont
aussi le rififi chez chez les
écologistes.
On commence par quoi ?
Paul Watson. Euh qu'est-ce qui se passe
pour Paul Watson ? Qui est-il ? Comment
il se retrouve en prison ? Pourquoi ?
Comment ?
Paul Watson, c'est quelqu'un qui a dédié
sa vie aussi pour le coup à l'océan.
C'est quelqu'un
Tu peux pousser un peu tes cheveux du
micro. Il y a mon ingénieur du son qui
quelqu'un de très euh ça fait souvent ça
hein, quelqu'un de très inspirant euh
qui euh
bah qui a fondé une association qui
s'appelle C Shepern euh qui est quand
même assez connu, relativement connu euh
qui qui sort un peu des sentiers battus
puisque il s'est fait connaître en
coulant des baleignés. Donc ça fait pas
forcément l'unanimité, y compris chez
les écologistes. He moi je me je me
colle pas trop dans la case des
écologistes d'ailleurs.
Pourquoi ?
Euh parce que je me reconnais pas trop
dans l'écologie
classique entre guillemets. Euh celle
qui pour le coup a longtemps condamné
aussi le genre d'action qu'on pouvait
mener avec si Shepern. Euh quand Paul a
coulé des baligniers par exemple, euh
bah le mouvement écologiste le lui a
reproché euh en disant que il allait
trop loin, que c'était irresponsable,
euh que c'était desservir euh la cause
de l'écologie, ce à quoi il a répondu.
Euh ben moi, j'ai coulé ces baleigners
pour des baleines. Donc trouvez-nous une
baleine qui désapprouve et je vous
promets qu'on le fera plus jamais. Faut
savoir que c'était des baleignés quand
même qui tuaient illégalement des
baleines euh qui qui étaient comment
dire au-dessus des lois qui se fichent
complètement de l'opinion publique. Euh
il a jamais tué personne, il a jamais
blessé personne he c'est des baligné
coulés à quai. Donc qu'est-ce que tu
fais quand tu as affaire à des gens qui
sont des criminels qui tuent en toute
impunité des espèces protégées et que
personne n'arrête ? Et en fait, c'est de
là qu' est né si Sheperd. En fait, c'est
de ce sentiment euh euh d'injustice,
d'impuissance euh du fait que bah même
s'il y a des lois et des traités, euh
euh des sanctuaires, des espèces
protégées, en fait au final, il y a un
gouffre entre ce qu'il y a sur le papier
et ce qu'il y a sur le terrain. Donc
qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Est-ce que tu
euh
tu continues à faire du jemp en Sarwell,
à faire des kermesses ou est-ce que tu
prends
B ? Il y a il y a plusieurs façons de
faire. Soit tu ignores complètement le
sujet parce que tu as l'impression que
finalement ça te concerne pas et bon tu
te dis que c'est dommage mais soit soit
tu le vis très mal, tu es en colère, tu
es triste, tu signes des pétitions puis
au final il y a rien qui bouge.
Soit bah tu décides en fait de prendre
les choses en main. Et c'est ce que ce
que Paul a décidé de faire. Moi, c'est
ça qui m'a plu aussi, c'est que quand je
l'ai rencontré, j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
qui tenait un discours qui était
combatif, euh qui était pas dans
l'attentisme, qui était pas dans le
larmoement, euh qui était euh proactif
et qui était inspirant. C'estàd que
l'objectif, il est de dire on n'est pas
obligé de laisser faire, on n'est pas
obligé de En fait cette impuissance là,
elle n'existe que dans notre tête et au
final bouger les lignes. Et je vais vous
montrer comment c'est possible. Et pour
moi, Paul, c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
montré par l'exemple que des choses que
je pensais être impossibles étaient
possibles. Et comme j'ai un tempérament
combatif et que bah à à l'époque où j'ai
rencontré Paul, en fait, j'étais un peu
investi dans dans Greenpeace, le WWF,
ces gros assauts compignons sur et je me
sentais pas à ma place. En fait, c'est
j'étais dans le dans le compromis.
C'était à défaut d'autre chose. Je
sentais bien qu'il me manquait un truc.
Quand je l'ai rencontré et que j'ai eu
cette philosophie qui est une
philosophie finalement biocentrique,
c'est-à-dire placer le vivant au centre
de tout. C'estàd que c'est pas l'être
humain au-dessus de tout, c'est l'être
humain euh qui fait partie d'un tout
avec une interdépendance entre toutes
les espèces. Moi, j'ai toujours ressenti
ça. J'ai toujours ressenti une profonde
injustice par rapport à ce qu'on fait
subir au reste du vivant. J'ai jamais
trop compris en fait pourquoi finalement
impliquer infliger des souffrances à
d'autres espèces, c'était c'était OK.
Pourquoi est-ce que la souffrance des
autres comptait moins ? Simplement parce
que c'est pas notre espèce. Ça, cette
hiérarchie-là, je l'ai jamais euh je
l'ai jamais comprise, même
instinctivement étant petite. Et donc,
c'est cette philosophie-là qui est
défendue. Et il y a pas que la
philosophie, il y a aussi l'action. Et
dans le fait d'aller couler des
balignés, il y a le fait aussi de euh
bah finalement de de reprendre le
pouvoir, de ne pas rester impuissant. Et
la polémique que ça peut susciter, je
trouve qu'elle est intéressante aussi
parce qu'elle est vachement
philosophique. C'est-à-dire que euh j'ai
je me suis renseigné un peu sur toutes
les critiques qui pouvaient y avoir par
rapport à ça puisqueencore une fois
quand tu coules des balignéers ça laisse
pas indifférent. Tu dis mais c'est des
tarés.
C'est quoi les critiques ?
Bah violence. Vous êtes des violences.
Vous êtes bah là aujourd'hui c'est le
Japon qui nous traite d'écoterroriste
par exemple. Et la violence qu'est-ce
que c'est en réalité ? Ça dépend où tu
mets ton curseur. C'estàd que quand tu
quand tu détruis un harpon explosif qui
va tuer illégalement une espèce
protégée,
est-ce que la violence finalement elle
est de détruire ce harpon ou elle est de
laisser faire ce ce braconni ? Tu vois,
de détruire la propriété privée d'un de
d'un criminel ? Est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est ça la
violence ? Tu vois, il y a il y a en
fait
est-ce que s'affranchir des lois, c'est
de la violence ?
Mais qui s'affranchit des lois ? Qui
s'affranchit des lois ? C'est c'est les
braconniers qui s'affranchissent des
lois. En fait, la question c'est si tu
marches dans la rue que tu vois
quelqu'un qui est en train de se faire
agresser, les flics sont pas là ou ils
sont occupés à autre chose. Ils ont
mieux à faire. Donc toi tu prends le
couteau, tu le détruis, tu sauves cette
personne. Bon, est-ce que tu t'es
affranchi de la loi ? Est-ce que tu t'es
occupé de ce qui te regardait pas ? Non,
tu as accompli un devoir de citoyen.
C'est exactement ce qu'on fait dans
l'océan. Voilà. Simplement, on parle pas
d'un être humain, on parle de baleine.
On parle de requin parce queon parle
beaucoup des baleines mais en fait ce
qu'on fait, c'est pour l'océan en
général. simplement, on part du principe
que si on arrive pas à épargner les
baleines qui sont hyper charismatiques,
bon bah c'est foutu pour tout le reste.
Voilà. Et donc en fait cette question de
la violence, elle nous renvoie
finalement à euh à la hiérarchie des
valeurs. C'est-à-dire que quand tu
estimes finalement que le harpon
explosif d'un gars qui tue illégalement
des baleines, il a plus de valeur que
cette baleine, bah c'est que ta
hiérarchie des valeurs, elle est
biaisée. La violence, elle est elle est
de l'autre côté. La violence, elle est
aussi à non assistance à espèce en
danger. Puis après, bon, ça c'est des
débats philosophiques si tu veux, mais
mais je trouve que la réponse de Paul,
elle est très très claire à ce sujet. On
l'a fait pour les baleines, on l'a pas
fait pour vous. Donc si ça vous plaît
pas, c'est pas grave.
Pourquoi il se retrouve incarcéré au
Grenland ? Comment ça s'est passé ? Et
pourquoi ?
Alors bah c'est simple en fait, on a un
pays qui est le Japon qui est une très
grande puissance économique mondiale euh
qui est dans une logique de vengeance
vis-à-vis d'un gars qui les a humilié.
C'est-à-dire que
pendant des années, Paul Watson et
Shapern, bah on s'est retrouvé en
Antarctique dans le sanctuaire balay
Antarctique qui un sanctuaire
international dans lequel le Japon avait
décidé chaque année de tuer illégalement
un millier de baleines en toute
impunité. avec des pays de partout dans
le monde qui disaient "Ah non mais c'est
honteux, il faut que vous arrêtiez,
c'est des espèces protégées, c'est un
sanctuaire" mais en fait le Japon s'en
fout.
C'était pas des des recherches
scientifiques ?
Alors ouais, ça c'est la Libye
effectivement du Japon qui a écrit en
grosse lettre sur tous ces bateaux
recherche sauf
recherche quoi ? Et ben c'est ça qui est
intéressant, c'est que quand tu regardes
qu'est-ce qu'il recherchent, en fait ce
qu'il recherche c'est euh la preuve
qu'il y a suffisamment euh de baleines
qui se sont rétablies parce qu'on a on a
failli toutes les exterminer, hein. En
1986, il y a un moratoire sur la chasse
internationale, sur la chasse
commerciale. Donc le Japon essaie de
prouver depuis 1986 qu'en fait si si
c'est bon, il y a assez de baleines pour
relancer la chasse commerciale. Donc
déjà l'objet de leur recherche c'était
de pouvoir recommencer la chasse
commerciale.
Mais c'est surtout qu'en fait tu as pas
du tout besoin de tuer les baleines pour
faire ça. Donc et puis les baleines qui
tuaient, elles se retrouvaient dans les
restaurants japonais.
Faut pas gâcher.
Alors oui et non parce qu'en fait malgré
le fait qu'elle se retrouvait dans les
restaurants japonais en fait les
Japonais ne mangent pas de viande de
baleine. Tu as moins de 2 % par an
tu as moins de 2 % voilà de de Japonais
qui mangent la viande de baleine. Et
donc ils ont lancé des campagnes
marketing. Ils essayent de séduire la
jeunesse avec le hamburger à base de
baleine. Ils ont même sorti la viande de
baleine à l'al
c'est-à-dire elle est abattue avec un
rituel. Alors ben j'avais fait un
article à l'époque là-dessus parce que
parce que pour le coup dans la direction
de la mec, tu vois avec le mec qui tue
la baleine qui à jour de ses abultions
qui a fait ses cinq prières
bismillah bismillahdillah voilà bon un
gros foutage de gueule mais comme toute
cette opération de chasse balère en
réalité la chasse balinière du Japon
elle est sous perfusion de subvention
publique. Elle coûte des centaines de
millions de de yennes au japonais, même
de dollars. Et en fait, tu as une
poignée de nanti de la droite
ultranationale japonaise qui s'accroche
en fait à des privilèges. Tu as les
yakuzas qui baignent dedans aussi. Euh
et en fait si tu veux, non seulement les
Japonais mangent pas de viande de
baleine, c'est une industrie qui leur
coûte hyper cher. En terme d'image à
l'international, c'est catastrophique.
Et puis surtout pour les baleines, bah
forcément, c'est dramatique. Et encore
une fois, on en est à bah une poignée de
personne qui euh qui finalement prend en
otage tout le monde avec un gouvernement
qui est corrompu jusqu'à l'OS, qui
aujourd'hui est en mode roule au
compresseur. Preuve de de la corruption
japonaise.
Ah oui. Ben à Commission Balinière
internationale, c'est alors il y a pas
mal d'articles qui sont sortis là-dessus
he sur le fait que ils arrosent et par
exemple tu as des tu as des pays
africains qui n'ont jamais chassé la
baleine de toute leur histoire qui
votent contre le sanctuaire le projet de
sanctuaire dans l'Atlantique sud et qui
vote pour pour la la rupture du du
moratoire. Donc en fait le Japon arrose
euh bah tout ce qu'il peut pour avoir
des votes euh pour faire tomber le
moratoire. Sachant qu'ils sont sortis de
la commission balinère internationale
euh parce que bah parce qu'on a fini par
les chasser l'Antarctique et qu'ils ont
perdu cette alibi de chasse
scientifique.
Donc voilà, tout ça pour dire que
aujourd'hui le Japon
Paul Watson débarque avec son petit
bateau, se jette contre le petit bateau,
tire des boules plusantes, coule des
balignées, joue aux autamponneuses.
Bah c'est un peu ça, c'est une sorte de
de bataille navale où en fait bah
pendant pendant des années, l'objectif
il était pour nous de trouver le navire
usine, le Nichinmarou qui est un machin
qui fait 8000 tonnes à à bord duquel en
fait il remorque les baleines qui sont
tuées par les harponeurs. Donc de
trouver ce bateau, de se placer devant
la rampe et de bloquer le remorquage de
la baleine. En fait, en faisant ça, tu
leur fais perdre énormément de temps. On
a pu sauver euh près de 6000 baleines.
Euh comment on compte ça ? En fait,
c'est parce que ils ont un quota qui se
sont autoattribués. qu'ils atteignaient
sans problème avant que cerd
interviennent et on a décompté en fait
toutes les baleines qu'ils ont pas pu
avoir du fait des interventions de C
Shapern. Donc euh on était arrivé à à
6500 baleines. Moi je disais 5000 mais
en fait c'est 6500 si tu décomtes du
quota qui s'était autoattribué. Et bon
bref du coup en fait c'est des millions
de dollars de perte. C'est une
humiliation aussi parce qu'il y a eu la
série téléaméricaine World Wars, ça
s'appelle Justicier des MES euh en
français euh qui a montré à des millions
euh de personnes en fait euh ce qui
s'est passé euh ce qui s'est passé en
Antarctique. Et donc euh faut savoir que
au Japon euh Paul Watson en tout cas
pour le gouvernement japonais euh bah
c'est un écoterroriste, c'est leur bête
noire euh et là si tu veux ils tiennent
euh je veux dire le mandat d'arrêt qui
est contre lui. Il remontent à des faits
qui se sont passés en 2010. 2010. Tout a
été très bien documenté. D'ailleurs,
c'est pour ça que Paul avait l'habitude
de dire que notre meilleure arme, c'est
la caméra parce que bah voilà, ce qui
n'est pas filmé n'est pas arrivé et puis
nous vu ce qu'on fait, on a intérêt à
tout filmer pour tout montrer parce
qu'en plus en face, on a des gens qui
mentent comme des arracheurs dedans euh
et on veut pas se retrouver justement
dans une situation où c'est notre parole
contre la leure. Donc tout est filmé.
Malgré ça, c'est là qu'on voit que c'est
délirant, c'est que euh ben en fait le
mandat d'arrêt a été accepté par
Interpol. Il y a quoi sur ce mandat
d'arrêt ? Il y a euh
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui,
voilà, conspiration d'abord, euh
destruction de propriété privée euh et
obstruction au business.
Alors ce qui se passe, il y a
obstruction commerciale.
Oui. Alors mais c'est là que c'est là
que tu dis c'est quand même c'est quand
même magique parce que il nous parle de
recherche scientifique. Non, ce n'est
pas du commerce puisque la chasse
commerciale est interdite. Il y a un
moratoire et en plus ils sont au cœur
d'un sanctuaire balaigné. Donc
évidemment que ça n'a rien de
commercial. Par contre sur le mandat
d'arrêt, ils mettent obstruction
business. Donc il y a trois dates à
retenir. C'est le 10 janvier. Le 10
janvier euh non le 6 janvier 2010, il y
a le Yushin Maru 2, c'est un
balainignier japonais qui percute de
plein fouet un tri marrant qui s'appelle
Ladyil qui faisait partie de notre
campagne.
Tout neuf,
il le coupe en deux. Bon, il était pas
bien vu. Il le coupe en deux. Ce bateau,
il est à l'arrêt parce que il est en
rate de carburant. Il le coupe en deux.
Il on a six membres d'équipage qui sont
à bord. Donc déjà, c'est hyper
dangereux. Euh et ce qui se passe, c'est
que ce bateau, il appartient à un gars
qui s'appelle Pete Betun
qui a rejoint la campagne de Chepd
uniquement pour cette campagne-là. Euh
un mois plus tard, Pete Betun dit à Paul
Watson, tout ça c'est filmé, hein. Il
dit à Paul Watson euh ce que je vais
faire, c'est que je vais monter à bord
de ce bateau-là et je vais montrer au
capitaine du Yoshinmaru la facture de
mon bateau et je vais lui demander des
comptes.
Paul, il lui avait dit "Peut-être qu'il
vaut mieux que tu ailles en
Nouvelle-Zélande, tu parles dans les
médias, tu racontes ce qui s'est passé
et cetera." Non, le gars il veut monter
à bord du Yoshin Maro 2. Paul lui dit
"D'accord."
Euh
c'est surtout l'autre capitaine, il a
dit d'accord ou pas ?
Qui ça ?
Le capitaine du Shimaru là.
Ah bah non,
il a pas dit d'accord mais il a je pense
qu'il recevoir sa facture, il s'en il
s'en foutait complètement. Par contre,
il était bien content ensuite de
l'emmener au Japon parce que ça leur a
permis après de lui mettre la main
dessus. Euh mais ce qui s'est passé
c'est que euh le 10 février, non le 11
février pardon, le 11 février, Pit Betun
est sur un semi-rigide de Chepern.
Zodiaque.
Un zodiaque. Bon, c'est pas un zodiaque,
c'est un semi-rigide. Mais bref, euh il
balance une bouteille de beurre rance.
Ce beurre rance, on appelle ça, c'est
une bombe puante mais on appelle ça
aussi de l'acide butirque.
Et alors bah les Japonais ce qui nous
disent, c'est que vous nous balancez de
l'acide. Sauf qu'en fait, c'est à peu
près aussi acide voire moins acide que
l'acide citrique, c'est-à-dire le jus
d'orange.
Je sais pas quel est le pH, mais nous on
en a eu sur les doigts et c'est moins
acide que de la bière. C'est du beurre
rance, ça pue. C'est dégueulasse. Enfin,
c'est ça, ça sent le vomi puissance 10.
Donc bon, l'objectif justement c'est que
ça pue. Tu balances ça sur le pont et en
fait pour eux du coup c'est hyper hyper
désagréable de bosser et puis surtout ça
rend la viande de baleine impropre à la
consommation. C'est tout l'objectif
du truc. Donc il balance cette bouteille
euh sur le bateau et ce qui se passe que
euh ce qu'ils disent c'est que euh ça a
giclé sur le visage euh d'un des marins
et du coup il a eu des bleus euh une
irritation euh à la joue. Euh nous on
dit mais c'est pas possible parce que
justement c'est pas irritant et puis en
plus euh pit bétune quand il balance le
la bouteille il y a personne à l'endroit
où il la balance.
Il la balance à la main ou lance-pierre
ou à la bombe à la bouteille sous
pression. Il a une il a un truc. Ouais
voilà. Ouais mais bon peu importe. Le
fait est que jou le paintball.
Ah je sais pas. Alors là je sais pas.
Mais en tout cas, il y a entre 1000 et
1500 bouteilles qui ont été envoyées en
8 ans, ça a jamais touché personne, ça a
jamais blessé personne. Mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant, c'est que ce qu'on
voit, c'est que quelques temps
auparavant, il y a trois gars sur le
même bateau qui sont en train d'asperger
bah l'équipe du semi-régide avec ils ont
des je sais pas comment on appelle ça,
des
extincteurs à lacrimeau.
Ouais. Voilà. et euh et ils font ça en
vant contraire, ils sont pas malins, ils
se le prennent en pleine figure. Euh et
donc en fait nous dit bah c'est ça qui
les a blessés en fait, c'est pas le
borrance. Donc ça c'est pour la blessure
qui est sur qui est sur le mandat
d'arrêt. Euh destruction
des ITT de chaque côté. Non, rien. On a
même pas vu de photo du gars. Il a il y
a rien eu. Absolument rien.
Destruction destruction de propriété
privé. Euh bah en fait, c'est parce que
quand Pete Betun est monté sur le
bateau, donc quelques jours plus tard,
il monte sur le shonan marou 2 avec sa
petite facture et en fait pour monter et
ben il déchire un filet antibordage que
les Japonais avaient mis justement pour
éviter l'abordage. Donc il y a un trou
dans le filet. Le filet il vaut 800
dollars. Il y a un trou dans le filet.
Voilà, c'est ça. C'est ça la destruction
de propriété privée. Quand tu vois ce
qu'ils ont fait à son bateau de 2
millions de dollars qu'ils ont coupé en
deux, bon, tu te dis qu'il y a quand
même voilà de poids de mesure. Et
ensuite donc Pétun monte sur ce bateau,
on le voit, tu as toutes les images, on
voit bien que il est pas du tout il est
pas du tout agressif, il est pas il est
pas menaçant ni rien. Il toque à la
porte de la passerelle, il y a un
japonais qui sort et il lui présente sa
facture. Voilà. Et donc en fait
pas dit Konichiwa. Ah, je sais pas, j'ai
pas le son. Mais en tout cas à l'image,
il a l'air très poli. Euh il rentre dans
la passerelle et puis euh et puis voilà,
il va passer euh 2 mois avec eux sur le
bateau euh et ensuite à la fin de la
mission euh et ben il le ramène au Japon
et là il y a son procès. Et alors il est
accueilli euh comme un terroriste. Euh
il euh
il est il est dans des conditions en
prison qui sont qui sont extrêmes. Enfin
moi je connaissais pas trop le système
carcéral japonais avant de m'intéresser
à tout ça. Mais nous en France, on en a
un petit peu entendu parler avec le cas
de Carlos Gone, mais on est dans un
système carcéral qui est moyenageux avec
un système qui qui est là pour vraiment
briser les gens physiquement.
Ils ont pas beaucoup de récidives
psychologiquement. Non, pour le coup,
tout le monde soutient carreau. Par
contre, ils ont une belle mafia de
Yakuza. D'ailleurs, il y a aucun des
Yakuza qui est sur notice rouge alors
que Paul Watson est dessus. Donc, c'est
quand même assez assez ironique. Mais
notice rouge Interpol.
Notice rouge d'Interpol. Ouais.
Du coup, en fait, ce qui se passe, c'est
que Pit Betun, il est dans des
conditions hyper difficiles. Il est
interrogé plusieurs heures par jour avec
des gars qui lui gueulent dessus.
Il il assiste à un viol dans les trois
premiers jours de son arrivée en prison.
Enfin et il lui explique que en fait il
va croupir en prison pendant des années.
À moins que à moins que il me disent que
c'est Paul Watson qui lui a ordonné de
monter sur le bateau.
Et puis tun, il le fait. Il le dit
d'ailleurs après he il fait une
interview où il dit "J'ai fait un deal
secret avec le procureur japonais et
j'ai dit que c'était Paul Watson qui
m'avait ordonné de monter sur le bateau.
J'ai menti. J'ai menti parce que bah
parce qu'il a eu peur.
Je pense qu'il ne mesurait pas à
l'époque les conséquences que ça aurait
pour Paul Watson parce qu'en fait c'est
tout ce qui leur fallait aux Japonais.
C'était cet ave extirpé sous la menace
qui leur a permis de lancer un mandat
d'arrêt contre Paul Watson. Du moment où
Pit Betun dit ça, ils ont fait ce mandat
d'arrêt. Donc euh conspiration
d'abordage, destruction de propriétés
privées, euh blessures, voilà,
houliganisme et obstruction au business.
Et là, ce qui se passe, c'est ça qui est
surréaliste, c'est que nous, on voit
bien là parce qu'on on creuse tout le
dossier et on démonte on démonte les
preuves parce qu'on a les image aussi
euh c'est que c'est fabriqué de toute
pièce, que c'est hyper grossier, que
c'est évident et le problème c'est que
Interpol ne mène pas la moindre enquête
et met Paul Watson sur la notice rouge.
Et à partir du moment où ils font ça en
fait, bah ils foutent sa vie en l'air
parce que euh bah il est arrêté en fait
à Francfort en 2012 alors qu'il venait
en France.
Bah parce que bah ça sonne quand il
arrive et euh et en fait c'est la
discrétion du pays. C'est-à-dire que
c'est le pays qui décide. Quand il
arrive en France ça sonne pas. Il arrive
en Allemagne
si ça sonne mais nous on est sympa.
On choisit on choisit de l'ignorer. On
se dit non on va pas arrêter Paul
Watson. Et du coup et du coup il est
incarcéré pendant pendant une semaine à
Francfort. Euh et au bout d'une semaine
il est libéré sous caution.
Donc euh il arrive à lever 250000
dollars
euh et pendant pendant 2 mois, il doit
aller au poste de police tous les jours
pour pointer.
Et euh et je me souviens que je crois
que c'était en en juillet, moi je suis
en Malaisie et je reçois un coup de fil
de Paul qui me dit
il me dit "Est-ce que tu peux venir à
Francfort d'urgence ? parce que lundi
quand je vais aller pointer au poste,
ils vont m'emmener au Japon.
Et en fait, on a eu l'info d'un indique
au ministère de la justice
allemand.
Du coup euh bah moi j'arrive à
Francfort. Oui, c'est ça. Francfort dès
le lendemain. Et alors là et ben on lui
achète une chemise hawenne, on lui tend
les cheveux, on lui rase la barbe,
on lui trouve un bateau
euh et on le fait partir de Francfort.
Il part tout seul.
Il part tout seul. Voilà.
Et du coup et du coup et du coup il se
retrouve sur un bateau et euh il
traverse l'Atlantique. Et là c'est les
gens ils savent pas trop ça mais enfin
il y a des choses qu'il a dû qu'il a dû
vraiment il a dû payer de sa personne.
C'est-à-dire qu'à ce moment-là par
exemple il y a son frère qui est en
phase terminale de cancer qui vient le
voir en pleine mer pour lui dire adieu.
Il sait que c'est la dernière fois qu'il
va le voir. Il sait que il sera pas à
l'enterrement et ils se disent adieu sur
le bateau et et Paul ne peut même pas
débarquer au Canada. Euh et ensuite ce
qu'il fait c'est que ben il repart euh
vers le sud et il se retrouve pour la
campagne antarctique l'hiver d'après.
Donc euh il nargu encore plus les
Japonais puisque leur dire je suis
toujours là quoi. Donc ils le prennent
vraiment comme une offense.
Il arrive très récemment au Groenland,
il fait le plein de sa barcasse et il se
fait attraper par les policiers
Groenlandais ou finlandais.
Non, Groenlandais en fait. Du coup, si
on fait un un
accéléré pendant toutes ces années-là,
Paul ensuite il a été aux États-Unis, il
est venu vivre en France pendant 2 ans,
il s'est marié en France,
l'a reçu.
Voilà, il est venu ici aussi. Euh puis
il est retourné aux États-Unis et il est
revenu s'installer en France l'année
dernière suite à un PCH qu'il y a eu au
sein de Cheburn mais on en reparlera
après.
Euh et donc là ce qui s'est passé c'est
que en novembre dernier, nous on check
sur le site internet d'Interpol et la
notice rouge a disparu. Donc on dire bah
tiens euh c'est une histoire ancienne
finalement. Bon, ils ont fini par lâcher
l'affaire au bout de 14 ans.
Et donc
le Japon qui a lancé son plus gros
navire baleignier, le Kangemarou en mai
dernier, a décidé en fait d'aller tuer
des baleines dans le Pacifique nord.
Donc pour Paul, c'est un affront
insupportable. qui dit "Je vais y aller
et je vais les empêcher de tuer des
baleines." Il l'a annoncé, il en fait
pas secret, hein. Euh et donc comme en
plus il est plus sur la notice rouge, du
du moins le croyons-nous, euh il va sur
son bateau. Le Groenland, en fait, c'est
le dernier port dans lequel il peut
faire le plein de carburant avant de
prendre le passage nord-est vers le
Pacifique nord.
il s'arrête au Groenland pour recharger
en carburant et là il y a 14 policiers
fédéraux qui arrivent
qui le menotent et qui l'emmène.
Voilà. Et on saura par la suite qu'en
fait c'est les îles ferroées qui sont
rattachées au Danemark euh qui avec
lesquels on est en on est en guerre
depuis depuis des années parce que il
massacre des dauphins. C'est le plus
grand massacre de Mamifermarin en
Europe. Les îles ferroées qui ont
prévenu la police du Groenland, qui a
prévenu la police du Danemark, qui a
prévenu le Japon. Ah bah il y a Paul
Watson qui va passer par chez nous.
Est-ce qu'il vous intéresse toujours ?
Et là, il y a le bureau d'Interpol du
Japon de Tokyo qui a dit "Oui, oui,
procéder à l'arrestation." Et donc
voilà, ils ont mis dans un avion 14
policiers fédéraux du Danemark de
Copenhague vers le Groenland vers Nou
pour arrêter Paul. Voilà. Et la suite,
bah pour l'instant, il est toujours en
prison.
Alors, il y a eu une audition, pas
d'audition. Quelles ont été les preuves
? Pas les preuves. Qu'est-ce qui est
incriminé ? Euh
bah, en fait, nous on a les preuves de
son innocence si tu veux. C'est ça qui
est délirant. Euh sauf que là on a à
faire un un juge au Groenland qui veut
pas avir les preuves. Donc là euh nous
on revient de la 3e audience. C'estàd
que Paul il a été arrêté le 21 juillet.
On a eu une première audience le 15
août, ensuite le le 4 septembre et là le
2 octobre. À chaque fois c'est le même
sketch. C'est-àdire qu'on a un juge qui
nous dit "Vos preuves ne m'intéressent
pas. Il reste en prison jusqu'à ce que
le ministre danois décide si oui ou non
il va être extradé ou pas."
Donc c'est ça qui est surréaliste, c'est
que déjà les faits qui lui sont
reprochés sont mineurs. Donc normalement
selon la loi du gros même s'il était
coupable euh c'est pas cible d'une
amende et déjà le temps de prison qu'il
a fait dépasse ce qu'il aurait dû ce
qu'il aurait dû écoper. Donc c'est déjà
délirant. Et puis surtout, on a un juge
qui ne veut pas voir les preuves.
Donc en fait, il a accepté de voir les
preuves du côté japonais qui sont dans
le mandat d'arrêt. Donc il nous dit "Bah
en fait, les chefs d'inculpation
d'accusation du mandat sont suffisamment
importantes pour justifier
potentiellement une extradition. Donc
non, je ne statuterai pas sur
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de plaider
le fait que ce soit un prisonnier
politique ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Bah c'est c'est un
dossier politique de A à Z. Alors le
ministre danois de la justice nous dit
"Non, non, c'est pas du tout politique
mais évidemment que ça l'est." On voit
bien que ça l'est puisque quand on quand
on a le déroulé en plus de du guet àapan
qui a été fait pour le stopper euh
guapan, selon vous, selon le côté
police, ça doit être une enquête
rondement menée.
Ouais. Alors moi, j'aimerais bien qu'on
me donne un exemple
de d'un cas de fait aussi ridicule,
aussi mineur, pour lesquels on déploie
autant
bah d'argent public, de policiers, enfin
14 policiers dans un avion pour un gars
qui euh serait complice d'un gars qui
aurait fait un bleu sur la joue d'un
type il y a 14 ans en Antarctique.
Moi je
C'est c'est tout ce qui lui est
reproché.
Mais c'est tout. C'est tout. Alors, les
pouvoirs politiques français,
les pouvoirs politiques américains, les
pouvoirs politiques canadiens, est-ce
qu'il a eu il y a eu une assistance
consulaire ? Est-ce que les Français,
les Américains, les Canadiens ont
proposé de savoir s'il était traité avec
tout ce qu'il fallait et s'il avait ses
médicaments, s'il avait chaud, s'il
avait suffisamment à manger ? Est-ce
qu'il y a eu une assistance consulaire ?
Alors, il me dit que oui, au niveau du
consulat euh américain et canadien euh
euh ils prennent des nouvelles. Bon euh
il est pas maltraité euh en prison
maintenant euh il est euh dans une
situation où en fait il est coupé du
monde. Il a pas droit à un téléphone. Il
y a d'autres prisonniers qui ont droit à
un téléphone. Euh évidemment, il a pas
droit à internet. Il a droit à 10
minutes par semaine pour appeler sa
femme et ses enfants. Nous au début, on
pouvait l'appeler à peu près quand on
voulait. Maintenant, c'est terminé. On a
plus le droit du tout. que ses avocats.
Euh tous ces codétenus euh bah il y en a
pas un qui parle anglais, il parle il
parle tous le grenis.
Quel type de codétenu il a ? C'est
la plupart c'est des gens qui sont euh
trafic de hachich beaucoup. L'essentiel
c'est ça
du trafic de de cheat
au Groenland.
Ouais, c'est très très répandu en fait
le trafic de cheit au Groenland. Je
savais pas mais voilà, j'ai découvert
aussi. Et euh voilà, pour l'essentiel,
c'est ça. Euh et euh et il y a aussi a
aussi un cas de un meurtrier pour
meurtre. J'ai pas les détails de
l'affaire mais il est il y est pour
meurtre et euh et et voilà. Et donc et
le problème aussi c'est bah ces
médicaments effectivement euh ça ça m'a
fait vraiment péter une durite parce que
il est diabétique, il a de
l'hypertension, il a un traitement qui
est très important à ce niveau-là et en
fait ils ont pas du tout anticipé à la
prison. Donc euh
j'ai son avocat qui m'appelle qui me dit
"Il y a un souci euh Paul son traitement
est terminé euh il y en a plus. Comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour lui acheminer son
traitement de France ? Moi, je venais de
rentrer en France.
Il y a pas de pharmacie au Danemark.
Alors si il y en a, mais ils avaient pas
son traitement à lui donc ils veulent
lui donner un truc qui est équivalent
sauf qu'il le supporte pas bien. Moi je
dis mais ils auraient pu anticiper parce
qu'en fait c'est eux qui lui donnent ses
médicaments tous les jours. Tu vois il a
même pas
Il a quel âge Paul ? Il va avoir il va
avoir 74 le 2 décembre.
Et euh et du coup euh bah du coup on
s'occupe de récupérer ses médicaments en
France. Donc moi j'y retourne là il y a
il y a une semaine, j'arrive avec ces
médicaments et à la prison on me dit "Ah
bah non, on peut pas les prendre. Euh et
lors de l'audience, je ramène les
médicaments et là j'ai la procureur qui
me dit euh la procureur qui est qui l'a
dans le collimateur, elle elle veut elle
veut qu'il aille au trou.
Elle me dit non, il y a pas besoin de
lui donner ses médicaments. On lui a
trouvé des médicaments ici au Groenland.
Je dis mais euh c'est pas son
traitement, vous lui donnez des trucs
alternatifs. Enfin que je sache, elle
n'est pas médecin. Donc donc là, je
commence à m'énerver. Il y a son avocat
qui me dit euh calme-toi euh je non mais
elle elle ne peut pas elle ne peut pas
me dire ça là. Elle crait quoi ? Que ce
soit un affaiblissement de l'image du
Danemark avec le Danemark est un pays du
tier monde pas capable de filer de
l'insuline à un vieux diabétique ou elle
a pris ça parce que elle pensait que
vous allez faire passer des substances
illicites ou qui lui permettrait de
mettre fin à ses jours.
Bon alors s'ils pensent que ses jours,
ils le connaissent vraiment pas du tout
parce que pour le coup c'est pas le
genre du tout. Euh mais non, je pense
que je pense qu'elle fait de l'excès de
zel. Euh elle est euh
elle veut elle bâtir sa carrière sur le
nom de Paul Watson.
Ouais. Alors pour elle, c'est un gros
dossier très clairement. Elle est elle
est clairement pas objective. Là la
dernière audience, elle a quand même dit
que Paul avait l'intention de blesser
des gens. Donc elle a caractérisé
l'intentionnalité.
C'est peut-être parce que elle a imaginé
que faire de l'autoamponneuse avec des
bateaux dans le grand nord, c'était
peut-être pas.
Non. Alors, c'est même pas là-dessus que
qu'il est jugé. Ça c'est pas sur le
mandat d'arrêt. Là, ce qui est sur le
mandat d'arrêt, c'est le l'envoi de
bombes fuyantes qui aurait soi-disant
blessé un des marins. Donc, elle dit
qu'il a l'intention de blesser
quelqu'un. Paul Watson, c'est un gars
qui est actif depuis 50 ans, qui n'a
jamais blessé personne en 50 ans, qui
dans tous ses discours a toujours dit
qu'il y avait deux choses qu'il
respectait, c'est la loi et l'intégrité
physique des personnes, de toutes les
personnes. Donc quand il intervient,
c'est face à des actions illégales, donc
face à des criminels et toujours de
manière à ne jamais blesser personne. Et
pour le coup, il a un bilan immaculé
là-dessus, 50 ans. Donc quand tu blesses
personne en 50 ans, c'est pas juste
parce que tu as eu du bol, c'est parce
que tu fais en sorte de ne blesser
personne. Et elle, cette nana, elle dit
il avait l'intention de blesser
quelqu'un. Et ça c'est grave.
Qu'est-ce que dit le juge ? Parce que le
procureur, je vois bien mais le
le juge le juge est une marionnette.
Très clairement, le juge, il avait son
jugement qui était déjà rendu sur son
ordinateur. Il a même pas il a même pas
pris la peine cette fois-ci de nous
faire le coup de théâtre, de suspendre
l'audience pour aller prendre une
décision et revenir. Non non, c'était
décidé d'avance. les D sont déjà jetées,
je fais même pas semblant. Euh le juste
qui dit c'est bah sur le mandat d'arrêt
japonais, ce qui est reproché, c'est
suffisamment grave pour justifier une
extradition. Donc euh je ne vais même
pas regarder ce que vous voulez
absolument montrer qui prouve que Paul
Watson est innocent. Euh il va retourner
en prison, je lui remets 3 semaines.
Voilà, c'est aussi simple que ça. Le
juge en fait, il a peur. Le juge, il va
prendre aucune décision. Le juge, c'est
un petit juge du grosland. Oui, c'est
c'est mon interprétation. il ne va pas
risquer d'être celui qui fait qui prive
le Japon de sa vengeance. Tu le Japon
est dans une vendetta personnelle là
contre Paul. Donc c'est pas le petit
juge du Groenland qui va qui va se
mettre en travers de ça.
Le ministre le ministre finlandais il
dit quoi
? Danois.
Danois pardon.
Alors ben lui il a un petit peu changé
de position. C'est-à-dire que ces
premières déclarations, c'était de dire
la justice va suivre son cours, nous
allons examiner le dossier, s'il y a
matière à extradition, il sera extradé
et sinon et ben on suivra on suivra la
règle la loi. Sauf que là, il a fait une
une réponse notamment à des députés
français qui l'ont interpellé sur le
sujet où il a dit quand même euh
pour qu'il y ait extradition, il faut
d'une part que la sévérité des faits qui
sont reprochés soit suffisant. Euh il
faut que euh l'intégrité physique des
personnes dans le pays qui est euh qui
demande l'extradition soit garantie et
qu'il y ait pas de mauvais traitement.
Euh donc là, gros clignotant rouge hein
par rapport au Japon. Et il y avait quoi
d'autre ? Euh le fait que il ne il ne
pouvait pas être extradé pour des motifs
politiques.
Ah bingo ! Bah si enfin le le dossier il
saute là-dessus
côté français. Vous avez eu des contacts
avec notre gouvernement et notre leader
charismatique.
Alors euh il y a une il y a une pétition
qui a fait presque 800000 signatures qui
interpellent donc le président Macron
pour prendre position pour Paul. Euh on
sait qu'à priori il l'a fait. Je sais
pas avec quelle quelle énergie et quelle
volonté il a fait mais il l'a fait.
Je suis en contact avec certains de ces
conseillers qui demandent des nouvelles
pour savoir comment ça se passe. Euh
voilà, pour l'instant
ter de personnalité médiatique autres,
il y a eu par exemple, je je pose la
question par exemple les descendants de
la famille Coustau, ils sont montés au
créneau il y a eu Oui. Non. Est-ce qu'on
a vu Brigitte Bardau monter au créneau ?
Oui, Brigitte Bardau, elle est elle est
montée au créneau carrément.
même pour son anniversaire, elle a posé
avec une photo Free Paul Watson, elle a
elle a parlé beaucoup dans les médias.
Euh non, on a eu quand même pas mal de
soutiens. On a eu James Cameron, Pierce
Brosnan dans les personnalités
internationales. Euh on a eu bah Hugo
Clément a fait partie des des fers de
lance aussi du
mouvement pour sa libération. On a on a
des groupes des groupes aussi de musique
comme Chacapon qui sur tous leurs
concerts font scander la foule. Fre Paul
Watson, on a Goa, on a pas mal de de
soutiens quand même notamment en France.
En fait, bizarrement, c'est en France
qui a le plus de bruit pour la
libération de Paul Watson aussi parce
que je pense qu'il y a il y a un lien
fort avec la France. Bon, si j'ai peur
en France, on est euh on est euh bah on
est là depuis 18 ans et puis on fait
quand même beaucoup d'actions euh et euh
Paul s'est installé en France, il a un
lien très fort avec la France et je
pense que voilà, il y a un vrai capital
sympathie et étonnamment en fait, je
pense que ce que fait si Sheperd, ça
raisonne beaucoup en France. Moi quand
j'ai fondé l'assaut en France parce que
c'est moi qui l'ai fondé en 2006, je
pensais que ça allait rester un tout
petit truc en BR. Je suis dit, on est
des taré pour la France, ça va pas parce
que on peut descendre dans la rue pour
les les droits sociaux, mais pour ce qui
est des animaux ou l'écologie, on est
quand même pas en tête de en tête de
liste. Et donc, je me suis dit bon pour
les Français, si Sheperd, c'est to much.
Et en fait et en fait non, pas du tout.
Euh finalement à l'international si chez
Porte-Fance euh c'est l'antenne la plus
dynamique euh de toutes et il y a un
vrai écho pour les actions. Il y a
plusieurs antennes, il y a plusieurs euh
je dirais brigade. Euh euh à l'étranger,
il y a il y a il y a d'autres si
Shepard.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est en fait en tout cas
dans l'esprit l'imaginaire de Paul, ce
qu'il voulait c'est que ce soit un
mouvement international
avec bah des antennes nationales qui
sont bien implantées localement et qui
agissent au niveau international de
concert. Voilà, ça c'était un peu son
idéal. Euh bon h malheureusement bah
c'est pas trop ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'il y a eu un chisme en 2022, on en
reparlera peut-être tout à l'heure mais
effectivement euh chaque antenne est
pseudo indépendante parce que
juridiquement elles sont indépendantes
mais finalement c'est là que tu vois que
l'indépendance réelle elle est elle est
quand tu bah quand tu es propriétaire du
nom et du logo et que tu es
financièrement indépendant ce qui est le
cas de de si Sheperd France mais ce qui
n'est pas le cas de plein d'autres
antennes de Cheperd qui du coup
dépendent d'une antenne qui qui
s'appelle Sicher Porte Global
aujourd'hui qui a été créé en 2013 qui
est basé à Amsterdam.
été créé par qui ?
Et ben en fait je suis condatrice de ce
truclà
mais qui a été créé aussi par Alex
Cornelisen qui est le directeur exécutif
Peter Amersed qui est en quelque sorte
qui était jusqu'à il y a peu le fils
spirituel de Paul qui était censé
prendre la relève mais qui l'a trahi
très clairement.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ?
Bah c'est un peu Brutus qui tue César,
tu vois. C'est c'est le syndrome du fils
qui tue le père. C'est votre
interprétation ?
Euh ouais, il y a pas mal de choses qui
permettent de de le démontrer aussi
parce que
je pense que il était dans une forme à
la fois d'admiration vis-à-vis de Paul
qui l'a qui l'a qui l'a formé de A à Z,
hein. Et en même temps, un certain
agacement parce que finalement
je pense que Paul est quelqu'un de très
charismatique euh qui l'empêchait de
briller d'une certaine façon. Tu sais,
l'ego c'est le c'est ce qui gangraine
tout et c'est le cas aussi
le fric,
l'ego, le fric, le pouvoir euh c'est ce
qui gangraine vraiment euh même le
milieu associatif aussi, tu vois. Et
c'est peut-être même encore pire en fait
je trouve parce que quand tu es dans le
monde de l'entreprise, tu sais pourquoi
tu fais les choses, tu les fais pour le
fric. quand tu es dans une organisation
et notamment une organisation qui a de
l'ora comme ça et qui suscite beaucoup
d'espoir et d'admiration chez les gens,
que les gens te regardent avec tu es un
héros en fait, tu vois. Si si tu as pas
la tête sur les épaules, si tu sais pas
pourquoi tu fais les choses, ça peut
très vite te monter au cerveau et euh et
ça et ça nourrit l'ego.
Et ces antennes à l'extérieur de la
France, est-ce qu'elles soutiennent,
elles ont le même combat pour faire
libérer Paul ? Est-ce qu'elles mettent
leurs ressources financières pour
essayer de d'avoir les meilleurs
avocats, la meilleure défense possible,
la meilleure couverture médiatique
possible ? Comment ça se passe ?
Bah non, non, c'est c'est ça qui est
terrible, c'est qu'en fait non seulement
si Shepard Global a évincé Paul Watson
avec un mail de trois lignes en 2022 en
disant "Tu ne fais plus partie du bureau
de Chez Global", ils ne lui ont plus
jamais répondu. Ils ne lui ont plus
jamais adressé la parole.
Pour quelle raison ?
parce que ils se sont euh ils ont envie
de
s'institutionnaliser en fait, ils
deviennent mainstream en fait avec cette
série télé WS dont je parlais tout à
l'heure, si Shepard a acquis une
notoriété
euh à gagner en puissance, en argent,
donateur et cetera et a commencé à
intéresser aussi des grands groupes
comme par exemple bah les assurances
Alliance euh comme la loterie
néerlandaise notamment qui donne des
millions à à She Shape Global. Euh et
puis ils ont commencé à développer des
partenariats avec des gouvernements
africains
et en fait ils se sont laissés tenter
par Ouais. par l'institutionnalisation
et par le fait de bah d'avoir des gros
donateurs.
Le volume d'argent de toutes ces ces
dépendances ou maintenant dépendances
qui sont affranchies, c'est quel volume
financier par exemple si chez part de
France c'est combien qui rentre, combien
qui sort et ensuite les autres ? Ben en
fait, c'est pas c'est pas tant que ça.
Tu vois, la France par exemple, nous on
est à un budget de 3 millions par euh
par an. Juste pour te donner un ordre
d'idée, euh Greenpeace France, c'est euh
plus de 25 millions, tu vois. Donc c'est
pas du tout et au niveau international
ils sont ils sont à plus que nous
évidemment mais par rapport à des
grosses machine comme Greenpeace ou
comme le WWF ça reste des petits pouss
Paul Watson il a pas de fortune
personnelle il a jamais tapé dans la
caisse il a jamais utilisé tout ça pour
lui.
Bah lui déjà il a été bénévole pendant
pendant plus de 20 ans. Et ensuite alors
comment
cour il a été payé ?
Il a été bénévole.
Ah bénévole
bénévole pendant plus de 20 ans. Et
ensuite il a été il a été payé aux
États-Unis. Euh, ils lui ont proposé euh
ils lui ont proposé enfin le gars qui a
récupéré si Shepur du S lui a proposé
300000 dollars par an pour euh juste
fermer sa gueule, tu vois, en lui disant
en fait maintenant si chez ça va devenir
autre chose, nous on va travailler avec
les gouvernements, on va être voilà une
assaut qui a pignon sur rue et cetera.
Toi euh bah tu as quand même un
héritage, tu restes un leader
charismatique qui a son nom a une
histoire donc ça les intéressait de le
garder. Par contre, il fallait surtout
qu'il la ferme.
Et ça ça a été verbalisé.
Il a refusé de faire ça.
Mais ça a été vocalisé, verbalisé par
ça a été verbalisé par le paraming qui
est celui qui a repris qui a repris le
Shaper du S par écrit, je sais pas. Mais
en tout cas, ce qui a été euh ce qui a
été écrit, c'est que si Sheperd devait
devenir autre chose,
s'institutionnaliser
et que clairement Paul d'ailleurs ça
devenait presque l'éléphant dans la dans
la pièce, le Watson problème. C'estd le
problème Watson. Moi, je trouve que
c'est un truc qui en dit long. Enfin, je
pense on écrira un bouquin là-dessus sur
le problème Watson en fait. Finalement,
c'est c'est ce truc originel, tu vois.
C'est un peu l'âme du mouvement. tu
vois, qui finalement fait chier ceux qui
sont arrivés après et qui ont voulu le
corrompre, l'emmener vers autre chose.
Et effectivement, c'est un gros problème
puisque
peut-être aussi leur propre motivation,
mais on les connaît leurs motivations,
elles sont elles sont évidentes. Leur
motivation si tu veux, c'est de se dire
bon nous on sait que aujourd'hui ce
qu'ils veulent c'est garder les gros
donateurs. Quand tu as quand tu as des
financiers comme alliance, tu peux pas
avoir un gars qui dit "Bah moi, je vais
couler des baliners, c'est pas
possible." Tu vois, si j'ai peur
d'Australie par exemple qui fait des
alliances avec Austral Fisheries qui est
une entreprise de pêche industrielle qui
va pêcher en Antarctique. Euh et donc si
j'ai
peut-être qu'il négocie une pêche plus
responsable
avec une empreinte CO2 moins importante.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Quand tu vas
pêcher en Antarctique, des poissons euh
qui vivent 150 ans, qui ont une maturité
sexuelle à à 30 ans, que tu vas même pas
vendre en Australie parce que c'est trop
cher pour le pour l'australien moyen,
mais que tu vas le vendre euh la légine
australe, mais que tu vas la vendre en
fait dans des restoics aux États-Unis.
Ouais, c'est le genre de pêche durable,
éthique qu'on a envie de défendre.
Enfin, de toute façon, c'est pas le rôle
de Shaper de défendre quelque forme de
pêche que ce soit. Maintenant, on fait
la différence entre évidemment la pêche
de subsistance et euh et et ce genre de
pêche qui est un un business honteux, tu
vois. Mais là, on a euh quand même une
antenne de Chepd qui est Sheper
d'Australie qui s'associe à ce type là
qui qui s'appelle David Carter, le PDG
de Austral Fisheries qui clairement
utilise si j'ai peur d'Australie pour
faire du green washing
peut-être pour apprendre à pêcher d'une
façon plus écoresonsable. et ben qui
prennent sa canne à pêche. Alors qui
nous prennent pas des navires usines euh
géants qui vont pêcher des tonnes de
poissons qui va revendre ensuite à des
prix euh à des prix exorbitaires.
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
institutions
se consigner sauver les bébés fog sauver
les baleines, sauver le désert blanc, la
main sur le cœur quand il voi les
Japonais ou d'autres pays aller
chasser, aller pêcher dans des zones
censé être des sanctuaires, ils font
quoi ? Ils vont aux Nations Unies,
tapent sur la sur la table en disant "Oh
là là, c'est pas bien japonais, c'est
pas bien."
Ouais, c'est ça.
Ils mettent des amendes, comment ça se
passe ? Non, il y a pas d'amende, il y a
pas de sanction. Alors que dans la
commission balinière internationale,
c'est l'institution qui régule justement
la chasse balinière, il y a des sanction
économique prévu pour ceux qui violent
le moratoire. Jamais aucun pays n'a
voulu mettre en place de sanctions
économiques contre le Japon.
Quel type de sanction et quel volume ça
ça ça représente combien ? Alors, j'ai
pas les détails, mais je sais que le
système de sanction économique peut se
faire. Notamment, par exemple, c'est ce
qui est fait contre le Mexique, par
exemple, sur la question des crevettes
parce qu'il y a des vaakitas, une espèce
de marsin protégé sur lequel le Mexique
ne fait pas le job. Il y a eu des
sanctions économiques qui ont été
prévues contre contre le Mexique, donc
avec une sorte d'embargo sur l'achat des
des crevettes. Donc, il y a des embargos
et des et des sanctions économiques qui
peuvent se faire, sauf que personne n'a
jamais voulu le faire contre le Japon.
Et donc tu as tous les ans ben euh bah
les pays les pays comme la France hein
notamment qui disent "Ah ben nous
regrettons profondément que le Japon
s'en tête a retourné chasser en
Antarctique." Voilà. Et donc moi quand
je vais en Antarctique la première fois
prendrait bien un petit sushi. Bah
limite c'est ça. Bah oui autour d'un
petit d'un petit buffet de sushi. Et et
en fait quand je vais en Antarctique la
première fois, je me souviens que
vraiment pour le coup ça te
c'est un peu une douche froide parce que
tu es dans un environnement qui est
complètement dingue. Tu vois des
baleines en l'occurrence, moi c'était la
première fois de ma vie que je voyais
des baleines. Donc déjà quand tu vois
des baleines dans un contexte normal,
c'est époustoufflant, il y a quelque
chose de magique. Ou alors c'est que tu
es mort à l'intérieur. Et en fait, tu
les vois et en même temps, tu sais que
elles sont traquées par des baleigniers.
Et je me dis "Mais en fait, on est là,
on est on est 40 clampins
sur un sur un vieux rafio qui a 50 ans
d'âge
en plein milieu d'un sanctuaire balin
antarctique au bout du bout du monde à
affronter les 40e rugissants, les 50e
hurl pour essayer de sauver ces baleines
qui sont protégées. Il y a personne
d'autre. Il y a personne d'autre. et on
est obligé de couper le carburant à bord
pour euh pour le pardon couper le
chauffage couper le chauffage à bord
pour gratter une semaine de plus, tu
vois, on dort avec des bouillottes et je
dis mais c'est délirant en fait, c'est
complètement délirant. C'est c'est ça la
situation en fait et c'est pour ça qu'on
fait ce qu'on fait. Et c'est pour ça que
quand je suis rentrée en France de cette
campagne là, j'ai créé six peur en
France parce que je me suis mais en fait
c'est les gens doivent savoir ça, c'est
c'est pas possible.
Les journalistes, il vous aident un peu
ou pas du tout ?
Euh benah, j'aimerais bien que les
journalistes, ils s'intéressent autant à
nous qu'ils peuvent s'intéresser euh à
Brad Pitt ou Kim Kardashian. Euh
tu sais ce qui te reste à faire ?
Ouais, je suis pas prête à tout non
plus, hein. Mais tu sais, Paul a dit une
fois et si je dois coller le message de
il faut sauver l'océan sur le cul de Kim
Kardashian pour que tout le monde s'y
intéresse, je le ferai, quoi.
C'est c'est terrible mais on en est là
en fait. Euh donc euh il y a des
journalistes qui en parlent, il y en a
qui s'y intéressent mais c'est tellement
à des années lumières de ce que ça
mériterait. Tu vois, en fait, moi j'ai
l'habitude de dire que l'écologie, on
appelle ça l'écologie, mais c'est la
plus grande cause humanitaire au monde
parce que il s'agit de la survie de 8
milliards d'êtres humains et de leur
descendance. En fait, si on a perdu ça,
on a tout perdu. Ça sert à rien de
lutter contre le cancer ou de lutter
contre quoi que ce soit d'autre. Si si
on est dans un effondrement du vivant,
aujourd'hui, c'est l'effondrement du
vivant, la première menace, hein. On
parle beaucoup du changement climatique.
C'est un vrai souci. Mais c'est d'abord
et avant tout l'effondrement du vivant
qui nous menace et c'est uniquement dû à
nous. C'estd que on est une bande.
Tu parles même pas de réchauffement
climatique. Tu
Je ne parle même pas de réchauffement
climatique. Je parle de ce qu'on appelle
la biodiversité. Moi j'aime pas ce terme
parce que ça nous exclut. Moi, je parle
du vivant en fait dont nous faisons
partie. On est la plus grande force de
destruction du vivant que cette planète
est jamais connue. C'est nous. C'est
terrible quand même tu vois. Donc on est
bien,
il y a eu la météorite et
on est pire que la météorite parce que
en fait on a on a enclenché la 6e crise
d'extinction massive qui est encore plus
rapide que la 5è qui a été déclenchée
par la météorite. On est on est pire que
des catastrophes nucléaires, on est pire
qu'une météorite, on est pire que ce qui
a déclenché l'extinction des dinosaures,
tu vois. Et c'est la première fois
surtout, c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de cette planète qu'il y a
une espèce, une seule qui se rend
responsable d'une crise d'extinction
massive. Donc aujourd'hui dans
l'histoire de cette planète, malgré
toutes les crises qu'elle a connu, la
plus grande crise d'extinction du
vivant, c'est nous. C'est le petit
primate que nous sommes, tu vois. Et en
fait, on est super fier de tout ce qu'on
a pu faire. C'est vrai qu'on fait des
trucs géniaux, hein. On écrit des
poèmes, des chansons, on est capable de
voilà cette technologie là, c'est c'est
super. Sauf qu'en fait, on est en train
de détruire la vie, on est en train de
se détruire nous-même. Et donc quand on
dit "Mais euh finalement nous ça va
quand même parce que voilà, on est 8
milliards et cetera. En fait euh tu
sais, il y a trois signes avant-coureurs
de l'extinction d'une espèce. Tu as
l'explosion démographique,
l'occupation de toutes les niche
écologique et la surexploitation des
ressources. Donc en fait là quand on se
regarde, on est en train de regarder une
espèce en voie d'extinction, tu vois. Et
en fait je pense aussi qu'il y a une
énorme là parce que là je te parle que
de biologie tu vois, je te parle
d'écosystème, je te parle de si quand on
dit si l'océan meurt, nous mourons.
C'est parce que très clairement c'est
l'océan qui régule le climat justement.
Tu vois, c'est le premier plus de
carbone, c'est le phytoplancton qui
permet de voilà qui a créé plus de la
moitié de l'oxygène qu'on respire. Et
c'est pour ça qu'on dit aussi que les
baleines, elles sont les maréchèr de
l'océan parce que c'est elles qui
fertilise le phytoplancton, tu vois.
Donc
une chose que les gens savent pas trop,
c'est que la baleine quand elle meurt,
elle participe à tout un écosystème des
grandes profondeurs qui permet la
migration et la colonisation des des
espèces de de gros cafar
du fond des mers. Et grâce à ça, ça
c'est aussi un biotope qui est très très
mal connu,
mais complètement. Et puis elle
séquestre aussi beaucoup de carbone et
et surtout de leurs vivants, elle
fertilise le phytoplancton qui en fait
régule le climat encore plus que les
forêts, tu vois. Et donc sans les
baleines, sans les tops prédateurs
marins, tu la machine climatique est
complètement détracé par
des déjections des baleines.
Je parle des déjections des baleines qui
qui comporte beaucoup d'azote et de fer
et qui est indispensable au
phytoplancton. Voilà pour ça que je dis
c'est les maréchères. les maréchères de
l'océan, c'est les baleines. Mais là, ça
c'est euh c'est une une dimension très
très biologique et très euh voilà,
presque utilitariste, j'ai envie de te
dire. C'est quand on dit "Oui, mais un
monde sans baleine qu'est-ce que c'est
?" Ben je un monde sans baleine, en fait
c'est un monde sans nous. Euh parce que
si on les a pas sauvé elle, c'est qu'on
a pas sauvé l'océan. Donc à la limite on
le verra pas. Mais mais je trouve qu'il
y a aussi une notion euh philosophique
hyper importante. C'est-à-dire que
enfin, tu vois bien que ça va mal. On va
mal en tant qu'espèce. Euh on n'est pas
bien, on est complètement détraqué, on
se met sur la gueule, euh on est bourré
d'antidépresseur, euh on est
complètement perdu. On est une espèce
complètement perdue. Et en plus, on voit
bien que c'est même pas proportionnel
au niveau de vie. Regarde en France, on
fait partie des pays les plus riches du
monde. On on est dans le top des
antidépresseurs. On n'est plus leader
mondial, je crois, mais on est quand
même dans le pleloton de tête. Donc tu
vois bien qu'en fait il y a un truc, il
y a un truc qui s'est perdu. Euh et moi
je pense qu'en fait c'est cette cette
déconnexion justement au vivant, le sens
de la vie. Qu'est-ce qu'on est venu
faire sur cette planète ? Euh en fait on
détruit notre propre famille. Ça n'a pas
de sens. Il y a rien qui a de qui a de
sens en fait. Et euh
quel regard tu portes sur
l'hyperfinanciarisation,
l'hyperconsommation ? Quel regard tu
portes sur les marchés financier ?
Comment tu regardes ce qui se passe en
politique intérieure ?
Moi je pense que enfin moi je te parlais
plutôt de de l'hyperconsommation
justement. Hyper Ouais.
hyperfinanciation. Hyperconsommation, je
pense que c'est euh ça répond à un vide
à un vide intérieur où tu essayes de
compenser quelque chose. Euh mais parce
qu'on court après des chimères.
Euh
c'est une consommation du monde parce
que justement on a perdu de vue
l'essentiel et sur une planète aux
ressources finies euh ben c'est
suicidaire. C'est suicidaire et puis
surtout c'est aussi creuser creuser les
inégalités, creuser les guerres et c'est
et c'est courir après quelque chose qui
n'existe pas. En fait, on détruit, on
sacrifie le réel pour le pour de la
fiction. L'argent c'est fictionnel. Euh
ça ça n'existe que parce qu'on y croit.
La seule chose qui est réelle, c'est le
monde naturel, tu vois. C'est l'oxygène
qu'on respire. C'est les arbres, c'est
c'est les c'est les animaux, c'est nous,
c'est le l'humain, tu vois. C'est ça qui
est réel. C'est la seule chose qui est
réelle. Et on sacrifie le réel pour
l'imaginaire.
C'est pour ça aussi qu'on est
complètement fou et qu'on est en train
de tout détruire. Quel regard tu portes
sur l'écologie politique
sur par exemple de Greta Thonberg à ceux
qui vont aller
faire la guerre avec les méga bassines
et les forces de l'ordre d'en face. Quel
regard tu portes sur tout ça ? Est-ce
que toi depuis ton bateau et ton permis
au Turier au 40e rugissant, quand tu
vois les parties écologistes,
quel regard tu portes sur ? Oh, il y a à
boire et à manger dans tout ça. Je peux
pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
dans le même panier. Tu vois, si tu me
dis les parties écologistes, c'est moi
je me retrouve pas particulièrement dans
les verres par exemple. tu les connais
bien mais pour pour l'ensemble de la
population les écolos ça reste les IP un
peu attardés qui défendent les petits
oiseaux.
Ouais. Je te dire
un écologiste dans le sens réel du terme
c'est quelqu'un qui défend la vie en
fait.
C'est pas c'est pas une étiquette, c'est
pas
c'est juste l'essentiel. Si si tu dis
l'écologie, je m'en fous. C'est comme si
tu dis la vie, je m'en fous. En fait,
moi j'ai fait des enfants mais je m'en
fous. S'ils crèvent demain, c'est pas
grave. J'ai pas besoin de respirer, j'ai
pas besoin de boire.
C'est complètement c'est qu'on a pas
compris en fait.
l'écologie, c'est c'est pour ça que je
trouve que c'est réducteur comme terme
euh maintenant les combats comme les
bassines,
tout ça, je pense que c'est des combats
qui sont qui sont hyper importants. Il y
a une forme de résistance face à une
énorme machine qui broie à la fois les
écosystèmes, les espèces, mais aussi
servi les mégacines.
Al
alors après, tout dépend comment tu fais
ça, bah tu peux toujours justifier. Ça
peut servir aussi euh de la Légie
australe dans un restaurant chic aux
États-Unis parce qu'il y a des gens qui
travaillent, ça crée des emplois. Euh tu
peux toujours tout justifier à partir du
moment où euh tu as de l'économique. Euh
la question c'est euh est-ce que tu es
pas en train de sacrifier l'essentiel
pour le superflux ? Est-ce que tu es pas
en train de sacrifier l'intérêt du plus
grand nombre pour un intérêt restreint ?
Est-ce que tu es pas en train de
sacrifier demain pour quelque chose
d'immédiat ? Euh
et un bon steak au rockfort,
ça se sacrifie ou ça se sacrifie pas ?
avec une bête bien élevée, bien qui a
bien mangé, qui a été bien abattu, sans
souffrance.
Ouais. Alors bah il y a plusieurs
niveaux de réponse à ça. Déjà, tu peux
pas faire ça pour 8 milliards d'êtres
humains.
Là, c'est assz de rock fort.
Là, c'est compliqué. Il y a pas assez de
rock fort et puis il y a pas assez il y
a pas assez de planètes en fait. Tu
vois, la première cause de déforestation
en Amazonnie, c'est l'élevage.
C'est le soja qu'on va faire pousser
pour nourrir les animaux d'élevage. Moi,
ça me fait rire quand il y a des
omnivores qui me disent "Non, mais vous
rendez compte quand même tous les
légumes que vous mangez, les
végétariens, non mais en fait, ils se
rendent pas compte que pour faire 1 kg
de 1 kg de bœuf, tu utilises beaucoup
plus de de céréales que ne va en manger
un végétarien." Donc d'un point de vue
écologique, il y a pas photo. Mais je
trouve que même d'un point de vue
éthique, si tu veux, moi j'ai arrêté de
manger des animaux à partir du moment où
où je me suis sentie hypocrite avec mes
valeurs. C'est-à-dire que
je sais que je n'ai pas besoin de
prendre la vie pour être en bonne santé,
pour bien manger. Voilà.
Tu as aucune carence ? J'en ai moins que
quand j'étais omnivore.
Euh, je sais que moi cet agneau, ce
cochon euh ou même ce poulet, je serais
incapable de le tuer.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que j'ai trop d'empathie pour lui.
Parce que je sais que ma vie ne dépend
pas de la sienne, tu vois. Et donc, je
sais que je peux très bien manger du
végétal, euh que ça sera bon, que je
vais pas me sentir puni parce que il y a
du très bon végétal. Faut pas faut pas
avoir l'impression d'être puni parce que
c'est important de bien manger. Euh et
donc euh et donc je serais pas capable
de les tuer. Donc j'ai pas envie de
payer d'autres personnes pour les tuer à
ma place. Tu vois, je me dis qu'à la
limite ne devrait manger des animaux que
ceux qui sont capables de les tuer
eux-mêmes. Je peux te dire qu'il y
aurait beaucoup plus de végétariens sur
terre.
Un peu comme la guerre, non ?
Ceux qui créent les guerres.
Bah qui aent la faire eux-même hein,
plutôt que d'envoyer les autres. Voilà.
La pêche euh pour moi, à mon sens, la
pêche qui euh qui se justifie
éthiquement, c'est la pêche de
subsistance. Parce queeffectivement, il
y a des populations, c'est pas ici hein,
mais dans certains pays, il y a des
populations où ils ont besoin du poisson
pour survivre.
Ça va venir hein
ici aussi. Ça va venir ici aussi.
Ah bah faut pas qu'on compte sur les
poissons parce que je vais te dire vu ce
qu'on a déjà surpêché sur nos côtes,
c'est pas prê on importe plus de 80 % du
poisson qui est consommé ici he parce
qu'on a déjà tout dingué. Donc il va
falloir compter sur autre chose que les
poissons.
Jamais tombé sur un filet de poisson
avec un espèce de bout de fil bleu à
l'intérieur.
Non mais très souvent.
C'est quoi le petit bout de fil bleu ?
Mais c'est des filets de pêche.
En fait les filets de pêche aujourd'hui
euh bah c'est c'est ce qui tue le plus
de baleines par exemple, tu vois. C'est
ce qui tue le plus de dauphins, de
mammifè marins. Euh c'est Ouais. C'est
ce qui ce qui pollue les poissons, ce
qui ce qui pollue l'océan, c'est les
filets de pêche. Et aujourd'hui, en
fait, ce qui tue, c'est ça le truc,
c'est que ce qui tue le plus de baleines
et ce qui tue le plus de dauphin
aujourd'hui, c'est le poisson qui est
dans nos assiettes. C'est la surpêche.
Et en fait, le problème c'est que tu
vois quand on parle d'un agneau à la
limite, si je te dis "Ouais, moi ce
petit agneau, j'ai pas envie de le
tuer." Tu peux comprendre, tu peux dire
"Ouais, c'est vrai qu'il est mignon."
Mais le poisson, poisson, tout le monde
s'en fiche du poisson. Quand tu dis que
tu es végétarien, on te propose une
salade de saumon très régulièrement.
Bah c'est ce qu'il y a de pire. Mais
alors, je recommande pas le le saumon
sauvage non plus parce que il est il est
dans il est pas bien non plus. Mais tu
vois, c'est très difficile de
sensibiliser sur le sur le poisson parce
que les poissons sont pas considérés
comme des animaux parce que voilà,
d'ailleurs, on fixe les côtés en tonne,
tu vois. Euh c'est tu dirais jamais 2
tonnes d'éléphants ou 2 tonnes de
chiens. Par contre, tu vas dire de
tonnes de requins, tu vois. Il y a il y
a pas du tout de sensibilité et en fait
c'est ça qui est qui est qui est dur
aussi de sensibiliser sur les poissons
parce que les poissons sont sensibles.
Mais les poissons sont sensibles, ils
sont intelligents. Ils développent euh
des amitiés.
Mais ouais. Quand tu vois un mérou,
quand tu vois un poisson Napoléon qui
reconnaît son pote qui va venir chercher
une petite caresse, quand tu vois une
murine,
toi tu es plongeur. Donc tu sais souvent
les plongeurs, ils savent ça. Mais moi
ça ça ça m'interpelle un peu les
plongeurs qui vont plonger avec les
poissons et qui le soir au resto vont
aller les bouffer. Bah
ça dépend.
J'ai jamais trop compris ça.
Pourquoi ? Mais parce que tu
tuas tu as eu ce spectacle, tu as eu
cette rencontre
euh mange autre chose. Tu vois pourquoi
aller manger finalement ce qui ce qui
t'a émerveillé alors qu'en plus c'est
pas une question de subsistence. Tu
vois, à mon sens, encore une fois, il y
a que la subsistence qui pourrait
justifier ça éthiquement. Mais mais
j'évite d'être donneuse de leçon
là-dessus parce que parce que moi j'ai
toujours aimé les animaux depuis toute
petite et j'en ai mangé longtemps, tu
vois. J'ai très longtemps été dans cette
euh dissociation cognitive, tu vois. Et
euh et je sais que ça marche pas quand
de l'extérieur on te dit les choses.
Simplement, il faut se poser les bonnes
questions. Quel
quel regard tu portes sur les les
plongeurs d'ailleurs qui chassent en
apné à la Gachon par exemple euh qui
vont tirer le poisson pour le manger le
soir ? Ben, je sais que dans certains
cas euh comme à la Réunion par exemple
euh ou ailleurs euh les plongeurs
sous-marins, ils ont dingué en fait euh
les fonds marins parce que ils sont
des bateaux des bateaux qui
Non non, mais même au harpon en fait, tu
as quand tu as plein de plongeurs qui
qui vont euh qui euh qui chassent et en
fait euh en fait c'est un peu comme si
chacun fait comme s'il était tout seul,
sauf qu'en fait on est nombreux et au
final mi bout à bout ben ça a un impact
énorme tu vois. Et donc c'est c'est pour
ça que je me dis euh si c'est pas euh
indispensable, pourquoi tu le fais
finalement ? Et d'avoir à l'esprit que
derrière toi, il y en a d'autres.
Je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
Sur la tradition de certains peuples
autochtones de manger une viande sauvage
de baleine ou de sasser ou de faire
marin.
Ouais,
c'est une tradition. Quel regard tu
portes sur cette tradition ? Quel regard
tu portes sur par exemple l'agneau de
pressalé du Montsaint-Michel
cuit 7h
qui se mange à la petite cuillère avec
une bonne bouteille de pinard bien de
chez nous.
Ah, il peut être très très bon. C'est
pas vraiment l'argument qui va me
convaincre. Tu vois, il y a des
traditions.
La tradition c'est quoi ? C'est ce que
tu as l'habitude de faire ? C'est ce que
tu as toujours fait ? Est-ce que pour
autant ça se justifie encore aujourd'hui
? Tu vois la tradition, c'est ce qui est
invoqué par les feriens notamment pour
massacrer bah des centaines de dauphins
globéphales. Donc ils tuent des familles
entières, des femelles gestantes.
Ils en font quoi d'ailleurs ? Ils vont
fait des croquettes pour chiens.
Ils en mangent une partie mais très très
peu parce que la viande elle est
impropre à la consommation. Il y a trop
de mercure.
Trop de mercure. Voilà, ils ont eu des
gros problè problèmes de retard mentaux
avec des ados atteints de la maladie de
Parkinson. Donc
il y a peut-être du plomb dans la
peinture. Non,
dans la peinture, il y a du plomb
malheureusement dans le dans l'océan. de
du mercure, des PCB, des métaux lourds
et cetera. Donc non, pour moi la
tradition ça justifie absolument pas de
continuer à massacrer des animaux tout
comme la tradition peut pas justifier
l'excision, la tradition peut pas
justifier l'esclavage.
Il y a il y a 1 et une tradition en fait
qu'on a aboli, qu'on a arrêté parce
qu'elle n'avait plus de sens et parce
que éthiquement on a évolué et qu'on
s'est rendu compte que ça pouvait pas se
se justifier.
Quel regard tu portes sur la société ?
parce que c'est une société d'immature
qui ont la bombe atomique
hypertransformant,
faisant de la cavalerie, billant tête
pour continuer un modèle qui est à bout
de souffle. Où est-ce que tu penses que
c'est le consommateur
qui a aussi sa part de responsabilité ?
Moi, je pense qu'on a on a tous une
responsabilité, mais surtout euh je
pense que ce qui ce qui fait qu'on a du
mal à avancer, c'est qu'on est isolé ou
qu'on se croit isolé, qu'on se croit
impuissant.
euh
et qu'en fait euh
ensemble on peut sans doute bouger des
montagnes et on est sans doute les seuls
à pouvoir le faire au final.
Crois toujours au père Noël.
En fait, j'y ai jamais cru parce que
toute petite ma mère m'a dit euh c'est
moi qui travaille et qui t'achète tes
cadeaux. C'est pas le père Noël, il
existe pas. Donc donc j'ai jamais cru au
Père Noël.
Mais euh mais je pense je crois à la
responsabilité euh je crois au fait que
on est au service de quelque chose de
plus grand que nous, que c'est comme ça
qu'on s'accomplit, euh que c'est comme
ça qu'on se trouve.
Tu es prêt à aller jusqu'où ?
Moi, je dédie ma vie à ça et je suis pas
une sacrifiée pour autant et je suis pas
non plus une candidate au suicide.
Par contre,
je sais qu'il y a quelque chose de plus
grand et de plus important que moi que
j'en fais partie. Donc, je suis pas
insignifiante, j'en fais partie. Mais
mais elle ne s'arrête pas à moi, elle ne
s'arrête pas à mes objectifs personnels.
L'abnégation.
L'abnégation, ouais. Le sens.
Euh tu vois, j'aime beaucoup la citation
de Ri, c'est un poète perse qui dit
"Nous ne sommes pas une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan, nous sommes l'océan dans
une goutte d'eau."
Et je trouve que c'est superin, j'ai le
mot en anglais mais je l'ai pas en
français. Empowering, tu vois, c'est
c'est c'est hyper fort en fait parce
qu'on a tous en nous le potentiel de de
changer les choses.
Pouvoirs, c'est ça,
de sa propre puissance en fait. tu vois,
de qu'on n'est pas aussi limité qu'on le
croit euh et qu'on on fait partie de
quelque chose de plus grand. Quel regard
tu portes sur la criminalisation euh des
écologistes,
la sémantique qui est utilisée, le champ
lexical qui est utilisé pour les décrire
comme échoterroriste et tout ce qui va
avec. Quand tu vois de gamine se coller
les mains et balan des balancer des des
boîtes de soupe sur des peintures,
est-ce que tu penses que il desservent
plus la cause qu'autre chose ou il il
servent la cause plus qu'autre chose ?
Et quand tu vois Paul Watson être mis en
prison, menacé d'extradition au Japon,
c'est la pire prison
qu'on puisse imaginer en terme de de
pour briser des âmes. Hm
hm.
Euh quel regard tu portes sur tout ça ?
Je pense que les défenseurs de la
nature, même si j'aime pas trop ça parce
que j'aime bien dire qu'on est la nature
qui se défend,
c'est souvent des gens écorchés, non ?
Ah, pas forcément. C'est des gens
peut-être qui ne supportent pas
l'injustice,
mais je pense qu'on fait peur, tu vois.
Je pense que ça fait peur au système et
euh et au fur et à mesure qu'on a des
gens qui se reconnectent à ça,
c'est-à-dire à l'essence du vrai
finalement du plus important de de là
d'où on vient, euh
ça fait peur au système parce que c'est
une menace finalement pour bah pour
toute cette société aussi de
consommation, tu vois, de capitalisme.
la nature, le vrai, le réel,
l'essentiel,
ça ça t'immunise en fait à cette société
de consommation qui essaie en fait de
t'attirer vers finalement un un gouffre
en fait, tu vois, et qui va en plus te
réduire à l'esclavage parce que
pour réussir justement à consommer, tu
as intérêt à trimer et en fait, tu cours
après quelque chose qui t'échappe tout
le temps et en plus en le faisant, tu
détruis le monde. Donc à partir du
moment où tu te recentres sur
l'essentiel, où tu te dis "Mais merde en
fait tout ça c'est factice. L'essentiel
il est là, tu vois ? Tu es un danger
pour les fonds de pension, les
retraites, le système financier parce
que si tu appuis de consommation
exponentielle,
si le taux de natalité implose, comment
tu fais pour payer le système d'avant ?
Bah de toute façon, c'est un système qui
est qui est qui est voué à s'effondrer
et je vois pas bien comment ça peut sur
sur la durée, c'est pas possible. Et
quel regard tu portes sur les
technolutionnistes ? Ceux qui disent
voilà notre nouveau dieu c'est
l'intelligence artificielle, ça va nous
sauver,
la science et la technologie vont nous
sauver.
On va nettoyer les océans, on va
nettoyer l'atmosphère, on va trouver de
la viande qui sera pas de la viande, ce
sera des cellules cultivé.
Alors moi je suis pas je suis pas une
antiscience, par contre je suis une
antiscientisme. Euh et le scientisme qui
est une sorte de religion qui consiste à
croire qu'en fait bah c'est justement le
technologie qui va tout sauver. Euh
c'est à mon avis très très très
dangereux.
C'est une façon aussi de fuir le réel
[Musique]
et
et non, j'y crois pas du tout même. Je
trouve ça je trouve ça assez effrayant.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses du nucléaire ?
Qu'est-ce que je pense du nucléaire ?
Je pose la question parce que en général
on nous pose souvent aux écologistes.
Bon alors écoutez les punk à chiens qui
portent des cervelles et qui jouent du
tamtam pour faire des kermessèes autour
de bassine en faisant bouou commencez à
nous ennuyer parce qu'on va pas
retourner à la chandelle. Ouais, on a
inventé la pénicine. Donc maintenant, tu
restes à ton côté, tu vas faire ta
psychothérapie, tu vas manger tes tes
tes tranches de tofou, puis tuembêtes
pas les adultes.
Tu vois, c'est souvent résumé
triellement comme ça.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Non mais c'est
Ouais. Ouais. Onouie pas de faire ton
petit caca dans ton pot de sûr.
Oui. Et puis et puis regarde la belle
éolienne que j'ai construit et puis et
puis le la voiture à moteur électrique
qui va qui va nous sauver. Mais tout ça
pour moi c'est des chimères aussi. Euh
pour moi le enfin même tu vois l'éolien,
on est assez critique de l'éolien euh
euh au niveau de au niveau de Shepard,
notamment l'éolien en mer, tu vois. Et
ça ça a étonné aussi parce que c'est
c'est aussi du euh du techno scientisme,
solutionnisme. On va vous coller des
éoliennes partout et puis vous allez
voir, on va résoudre les problèmes. Euh
non, on voit bien qu'en fait ça marche
pas, que bah que des éoliennes au cœur
des aires marines protégées avec des
destructions de d'espèces protégées pour
coller des éoliennes euh va chercher
aussi les matières premières qui sont
nécessaires pour tout ça. Les nodules
polymétalliques qu'on va aller chercher
dans les grands fonds marins, bah c'est
pour les batteries des voitures
électriques. Donc non, si on me dit "Ah
donc OK, tu es écolo, donc tu as une
voiture électrique ?" Non, j'ai pas de
voiture électrique et je pense pas que
ça va être la solution. Euh
moi je roule au mazout madame.
Mais voilà, enfin c'est il y a pas de il
y a pas de solution bagi magique avec
les pseudo énergie renouvelable. Euh
alors je dis pas que il faut euh il faut
pas en faire du tout, mais en tout cas
pas n'importe comment. Euh et là on est
dans la grande tendance aussi qui
consiste à sacrifier le vivant justement
au prétexte de lutter contre le
changement climatique parce qu'il y a un
énorme business qui s'est construit par
rapport à ça. Donc voilà, coller des
éoliennes partout, des panneaux
photovoltaïques et des batteries
électriques pour lutter contre le
changement climatique. C'est pas grave
si on détruit les derniers habitats
naturels, si on détruit les espèces
protégées,
on aura lutter contre le changement
climatique. Sauf que le premier organe
de régulation du climat, comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure, c'est l'océan. Tu
détruis la vie marine, c'est même plus
la peine. Donc c'est complètement
délirant. Et là, on est encore en train
de faire fausse route alors qu'on peut
plus se permettre de faire fausse route
parce qu'on a déjà tellement tout dingué
que non, il va falloir qu'en fait on
prenne le problème à la racine. Le
problème c'est que on est dans un mode
de pensée, dans un mode de vie euh qui
est pas le bon. On a mis le curseur sur
ben sur la surconsommation, sur le
factice, sur l'artificiel, sur sur le
virtuel
et pas sur l'essentiel et pas sur le
réel.
Donc voilà,
comment tu verrais les choses pour pour
sensibiliser pour qu'il y ait un
changement de schéma, un changement de
de pour utiliser le le mot anglais, le
pattern ? Comment comment on fait pour
changer ça ? Pour mettre une petite
graine, on laisse Greta Tenberg
manifester ?
Non,
on fait des cours, on fait des cours
dans les écoles. On on fait
Alors, oui, au niveau de l'éducation,
clairement, on a des des années de
retard. Enfin, moi je je trouve assez
affligeant le niveau au niveau de
l'éducation nationale euh ce qu'on peut
ce qu'on peut transmettre aux enfants.
Mais ma réponse va peut-être te
surprendre. Je pense que la réponse,
elle est elle est grandement
spirituelle. Je pense qu'on est euh on
est en perte de spiritualité. C'est pas
je parle pas de religieux, je parle de
spirituel vraiment euh de connexion, de
sens, tu vois. Et euh et je pense que
parce qu'on est des êtres spirituels,
qu'on le veuille ou non, parce qu' on
est en quête de sens, tu vois tout ce
qu'on fait, même la dimension
artistique, onirrique, on a besoin de
trouver du sens à ce qu'on fait, tu
vois, parce que on est autre chose que
des machines de chair et de sang, tu
vois. Et or bah justement cette société
de consommation matérialiste,
capitaliste, elle a complètement
annihilé le côté spirituel. On est en
plus dans euh un dogme qui est le dogme
de la laïcité qui a eu tendance à
complètement gommer aussi la partie
spirituelle. C'est comme si on a jeté
les religions mais on a jeter la
spiritualité avec et en fait du coup on
a perdu le sens
le sens pourquoi on est là en fait.
Tu crois quelque chose ?
Je crois que encore une fois, on fait
partie de quelque chose de plus grand
euh qu'on qu'on sert quelque chose de
plus grand euh et que
que la réalité est bien plus bien plus
grande que celle euh que celle qu'on
perçoit.
Je pense qu'il y a je pense qu'il y a un
sens à tout ça. Je pense qu'on a des
choses à apprendre, qu'on expérimente
des choses en étant là et que
je pense que tu es bien quand tu as le
sentiment d'être en adéquation avec
quelque chose. Tu vois, moi finalement,
j'ai toujours suivi ma petite voix
intérieure qui avait pas l'air
particulièrement rationnelle par rapport
à ce que je pouvais avoir autour de moi,
tu vois. Sinon, j'aurais jamais suivi le
parcours que j'ai suivi.
Tes parents, il ils ont eu quel regard
quand tu as commencé à aller faire
Youyou sur les bateaux pour aller faire
la chasse à la baleine au n chasse au
baligier ?
Bah, mon père était épicier, tu vois. Et
euh et ma mère euh ma mère, elle aurait
voulu que je sois employée à la mairie
de Jeuneviler
à 15 minutes de chez elle. Elle aurait
adoré, tu vois. C'est fonctionnaire.
Alors fonctionnaire, c'était la
sécurité. Elle elle était femme de
ménage, tu vois. Donc rien que le fait
que de travailler sur un bureau pour
elle c'était voilà en même temps elle me
disait ça puis me dis monsieur après si
tu es médecin c'est bien aussi mais
enfin des très très classique très très
carthésien enfin combien si Shepard te
rémunère
euh 3200 €
net brut
net
logement de fonction désavantages en
nature
non j'ai pas de logement de fonction non
j'ai pas d'avantage en nature si ce
n'est que bah quand je me déplace pour
si peurne je suis forcément déffrayé
mais mais voilà
qu'est-ce que Paul Il il risque s'il est
extradé au Japon.
Bah ce que je disais tout à l'heure,
c'est que je pense qu' il vaudrait mieux
lui tirer une balle dans la tête que
l'extrader au Japon. Parce que si
l'extradé au Japon, il faut pas lui
tirer une balle dans la tête.
Non mais il Ah non, évidemment que non.
Mais il vaudrait mieux ça que de
l'extrader au Japon parce que ce qu'il
attend au Japon euh c'est l'humiliation,
la torture. On le reverra jamais très
clairement. Le Japon est vraiment dans
une quête de vengeance. Je vous invite à
regarder, il y a des documentaires sur
YouTube sur le système carcéral au
Japon, la façon dont il brisent les
gens. Tu as 99,6
% de condamnation au Japon. Tu as aucune
chance en fait.
Un mec d'ailleurs qui qui était enfermé
depuis un certain temps, il était
tellement brisé que ils sont rendus
compte qu'il était peut-être quand même
innocent.
Il était innocent. Ouais. Ils ont foutu
sa vie en l'air. Euh et en fait euh par
rapport à Paul et en fait il y a des
rapports comme ça d'amnistie
internationale qui sont sorti de Human
Rights Swatch sur la façon dont sont
traité euh notamment les activistes et
particulièrement les activistes
occidentaux dans les prisons japonaises.
Ils ont un traitement de faveur parce
que tu as énormément de racisme en fait
au Japon contre les Blanc occidentaux et
alors encore plus les activistes comme
Paul Watson. Donc euh ils vont tout lui
enver s'excuse et il ne s'excusera pas.
Il ne s'excusera jamais. C'est pour lui
s'excuser, c'est c'est renier toute sa
vie, tout ce qu'il a fait. Donc euh je
ne veux même pas imaginer euh ce qu'ils
vont lui faire. C'est pour ça que quand
je dis il vaudrait mieux lui tirer une
balle dans la tête que de l'envoyer
là-bas, ça paraît violent. Mais
honnêtement, c'est vrai et c'est hyper
important que le Danemark se rende
compte de s'il fait s'il fait une greffe
de la fin au Japon,
ils vont lui mettre une petite sonde, le
nourrir, comment ça va se passer ?
Non, mais je pense que s'il doit faire
une greffe de la fin, il faut qu'il la
fasse avant d'aller au Japon parce que
une fois qu'il est au Japon, à la
limite, ils vont dire "Bah, tant mieux,
tu nous facilites le boulot, tu enfin je
pense qu'une fois qu'il est au Japon,
c'est terminé. C'est terminé." Et
d'ailleurs, je fais une petite
parenthèse sur Amnestie parce que euh
font
les mêmes rapports d'ailleurs sur nos
propres prisons en France, hein.
D'ailleurs,
d'accord. Euh au au point au point du
Japon,
moi je je veux bien je veux bien
comparer, mais on a on a contacté
Amnestie parce qu'il y a pas mal de gens
qui ont contacté Amnesty pour demander
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont à ce point
silencieux sur le cas de Paul Watson. Et
alors, ils nous répondent "Ben, on
travaille pas sur le dossier de Paul
Watson."
Donc, j'ai répondu "Mais en fait, à la
limite, on vous demande même pas de vous
exprimer sur sa supposée culpabilité.
pas culpabilité. OK, vous connaissez pas
le dossier, mais extrader un activiste
euh occidental au Japon qui chassait des
baleines de manière illégale en
Antarctique, est-ce que juste vous
pouvez dire on va à l'extrader au Japon,
c'est peut-être pas une bonne idée,
sachant que le système carcéral au Japon
est-ce qu'il est. Rien que ça, ils n'ont
pas voulu le faire.
Donc moi, je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a
derrière ça. On a eu un activiste de
Shaperd aussi qui s'est retrouvé en
prison au Japon en 2011 et Amnesty avait
pas voulu se mobiliser pour lui. Donc
qu'est-ce qu'il avait fait pour se
retrouver en prison ?
Il était sur les massacres de dauphin et
en fait il filmait les massacres de
dauphins à Taiji. Il y a un documentaire
qui s'appelle de Cve qui est euh très
difficile à regarder mais sur les
massacres de dauphins qui sont financés
par l'industrie de la captivité en fait.
Donc en fait, il payent les pêcheurs de
Taiji pour aller capturer des dauphins.
Euh bah les dauphins qui sont vieux, pas
beaux, machin, enfin pas beau. Ça existe
pas les dauphins pas beau, mais ceux qui
sont pas choisis euh sont tués. Ils sont
réduits en pâté pour chien ou en
fertilisant et puis où ils vont dans les
cantines pour les pauvres et euh et les
autres euh ils sont récupérés pour les
Delphinarium
et donc c'est eux qui les financent. Et
donc c'est les massacres annuels.
D'ailleurs, ça commence en septembre là.
Ça ça a commencé en septembre, c'est de
septembre à mars. Euh c'estable
et en fait bah si je sais pas, on a eu
des campagnes pendant des années là-bas
et donc Erwin, le gars dont dont je
parle était sur place et il documentait
tout ça et en fait il a été accusé par
un japonais de l'avoir bousculé
alors que en fait Erwin, il passe devant
ce mec-là, il a les deux mains prises.
Il a pu prouver au bout de 2 mois de
prison qu'en fait il avait rien fait,
que le mec avait menti. Sauf
queentre-temps, il a perdu 10 kg. Il a
vu personne, il était à l'isolement, il
assis devant le mur.
Ouais, il doit enfin c'est eux qui te
disent où tu dois regarder, comment tu
dois te positionner. C'était en plein
hiver, les gardiens, ils étaient avec
des gros manteaux, lui il était en
pyjama. Euh
si sil obéit pas, qu'est-ce qui s'expose
à quoi ? Il a pas de dessert à la
cantine ou il se font des coups de bâton
? Ah non, ils peuvent se faire taper.
Alors ça c'est ce que j'ai vu dans les
documentaires où le gars par exemple qui
a regardé un gardien qui se fait rosser
enfin voilà et lui là Erwin
Erwin bah c'est pareil à l'époque du
coup ouais il avait demandé l'aide enfin
sa femme qui avait demandé l'aide
d'Amnestie Internationale et ils avaient
pas eu d'aide
donc je sais pas
les autres associations dites
écologistes de la protection du vivant
comme Greenpeace WWF et j'en passe
ils ont été solidaires avec vous ils On
essayer de poser des choses.
Alors WWF, on les a pas entendu, ils
sont pas venus. On a Canopé, c'est une
association qui défend les forêts qui
nous a aidé à organiser le grand
rassemblement de place République le 4
septembre. On a eu la fondation Brigitte
Bardau qui s'est pas mal mobilisé. On a
aussi on a eu d'autres assauts aussi One
Voice mais tu vois finalement c'est
plutôt des petites assauts. Euh bon, on
a le DG de Greenpeace qui est venu au
rassemblement mais Greenpiece ne s'est
pas mobilisé en tant que Greenpiece.
Mais tout comme si porte global ne s'est
pas mobilisé pour Paul, tu vois, il y a
que si porte France en fait qui s'est
mobilisé pour Paul. Si porte France et
si Brésil euh global en fait, ils se
prennent un max de donation parce que
les gens pensent que Paul est toujours
avec C She Shapern et donc ils ont eu
des augmentations de dons et de et de
vente de merchandising parce que les
gens en fait les soutiennent pour aider
Paul. Et d'ailleurs dans les courriers
que Paul a reçu en prison, il y a des
gens qui lui disent "Ah bah j'ai fait un
don à si peur d'Allemagne pour pour
t'aider." Sauf que si j'ai peur
d'Allemagne, ils ont viré Paul comme un
mal propre et les gens sont pas au
courant. Donc bon, c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu un petit peu
frustrant mais
après tu vois, il y a eu il y a eu aussi
des Moi, j'ai fait un un texte que je
vais publier bientôt sur Paul parce que
euh du fait queon parle beaucoup de lui,
il y a eu aussi des polémiques qui sont
ressorties sur des choses qu'il a pu
dire et qui ont été sorties de leur
contexte. euh des choses qui m'ont
toujours énervé mais que j'ai ignoré,
que lui aussi a ignoré et que
aujourd'hui en fait me font vraiment mal
euh euh personnellement et donc sur
lesquels je vais prendre la peine de
répondre. Euh notamment des accusations
de racisme, de génisme
euh une
super fortune.
Ah oui ! Ah oui ! Ça, j'ai même pas
répondu.
Ouais, moi ça honnêtement, je me suis
même pas abaissé à répondre à ça. Si
Paul était riche, ça se saurait. on en
serait pas là où on en est aujourd'hui.
Il a dû repartir à zéro quand il l'
virait comme un comme un mal propre de
de global. Donc euh
non, c'est euh plutôt des trucs qui qui
sont qui ont été sortis de leur contexte
ou qui ont été déformés par exemple sur
l'immigration mexicaine. Tu vois, c'est
un truc que j'ai beaucoup entendu. Paul
est contre l'immigration, notamment
l'immigration mexicaine en fait. Non, il
est contre le système de l'agroindustrie
américaine qui exploite en fait et qui
réduit à l'esclavage les travailleurs
mexicain parce que justement ils ont une
mane infinie de travailleurs illégaux
qui viennent et qui font que en fait ben
la nana qui est femme de chambre à
l'hôtel ou qui travaille
au champ, elle aura jamais
d'augmentation et elle sera toujours
traitée comme une esclave parce que de
toute façon si elle est pas contente,
elle est remplacée. C'est ça qu'il a
dénoncé en fait. Donc et à chaque fois
enfin il y a des il y a des trucs comme
ça qui ressortent et qui qui sont assez
euh
quand tu pars sur une campagne, c'est
toi le skiper, c'est pas toi le skiper.
Qu'est-ce que quel rôle tu as à
l'intérieur d'un mato ?
Alors ça dépend quand je suis partie les
premières fois j'ai été quartier maître
donc j'étais à la navigation. Alors je
suis pas officier he parce que moi quand
j'ai commencé, j'avais aucune j'avais
aucune aucune formation.
Je rigole parce que c'est drôle ce que
je vois. J'avais aucune formation quand
j'ai commencé. Donc j'ai tout appris sur
le teint, tu vois. Mais c'est un peu
l'école de la vie aussi. C'est ça qui
est qui est assez cool. Je me souviens
de mes premières tempêtes justement ben
dans les 40e rissons, c'était assez
hallucinant. Et moi j'étais euh j'étais
j'étais au pilotage mais alors il y
avait Paul qui était à côté et on était
on était très mal placé par rapport aux
vagues et on enfin on risquait de se de
de basculer et j'ai en mémoire Paul qui
arrive mais non chalant c'est limite il
était en train de se brosser les dents
qui me replace le bateau comme il faut
tac tac à la bonne vitesse pas trop vite
pas trop lentement tac qui remet ok bon
j'ai beaucoup appris avec lui notamment
sur ben ouais son son fle mais son son
aisance même dans les mers les plus
démontées du monde. Et donc j'étais à la
passerelle et puis après maintenant
quand je vais sur les campagnes déjà j'y
vais pas aussi longtemps qu'avant.
Euh et donc ben le capitaine il est là,
moi je vais je vais surtout être chargé
de mission en fait. Donc moi je
réfléchis la stratégie, la
communication. Euh je vais sur le
terrain parce que c'est hyper important
pour moi d'être sur le terrain. Euh
c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé, c'est
ce qui me nourrit. D'ailleurs, toutes
les personnes qui travaillent avec moi
qui sont pas forcément sur le terrain
euh et ben on fait en sorte qu'elles
puissent aller sur le terrain euh assez
régulièrement parce que tu reviens
chargé à bloc. C'est euh c'est c'est tu
peux pas euh tu peux pas gérer une
organisation comme ça en étant euh en
étant dans dans un bureau tout le temps.
Euh c'est important de rester connecté
puis rester connecté aussi avec les
équipes. Euh et donc euh et donc j'adore
ça mais voilà, j'ai j'ai plus un un rôle
si tu veux particulier euh sur le bateau
comme je pouvais avoir quand j'ai
commencé.
Il y a d'autres navigateurs ou
navigatrices qui ont essayé de monter au
créneau ? Et ben écoute, il y a Eugène
Rigidel euh et Joe Logen. Alors c'est
deux navigateurs breton. Eugène, il a 84
ans et euh et Jo, il a 74 ans. Et ils
sont allés s'enchaîner euh à la
concession Toyota de Valencienne la
semaine dernière. Et moi, j'ai trouvé ça
génial quand ils m'ont appelé, ils m'ont
dit "Bah, on va aller s'enchaîner parce
que voilà, on trouve ça dégueulasse ce
qui se passe."
Et je dit "Putain, ils ont 84 et 74 ans
et c'est eux qui vont s'enchaîner
à la concession Toyota." Je trouvais ça
super beau. Bah ouais, on est vieux mais
on est encore vivant et ouais on va le
faire quoi. Cool
du côté du côté de la famille Carson, la
famille Coustau.
C'est pas une nouvelle.
Non.
Vous avez des contacts avec eux ?
Bah non.
Vous en voulez ?
Bah tous ceux qui veulent aider on est
on est preneur. Enfin je veux dire on va
on va snobber personne mais j'ai pas eu
de contact de leur part. les
explorateurs des mers ou les
explorateurs tout courts, par exemple
Myorn ou d'autres.
Euh non, c'est Myorn, il a pas fait un
petit poste sur ses réseaux peut-être.
J'ai je crois que j'ai vu passer quelque
chose mais euh mais pas plus que ça.
Non, honnêtement finalement
son père Trampicard, il a pas pris son
téléphone. Non
non
non. Après, je surveille pas non plus
tous les réseaux. C'estàd que il peut y
avoir eu des posts qui ont été faits et
et moi j'ai pas vu souvent il y a des
gens qui m'envoient des trucs,
honnêtement je les aurais pas vu
autrement mais en personnes qui se sont
vraiment mobilisé qui sortent du lot
clairement Hugo Clément le jour même euh
le jour même il était il était il était
au taquet et c'est vrai que Chakaaponk
et Gogira
vraiment sortent du lot parce que
aujourd'hui si tu vas sur le site
internet de Shakaponk bah tu arrives sur
six Shepard tu vois sheperd français
On a des gens qui nous contactent qui
disent "Nous cherchons à joindre
chacaponk mais en fait on n'y arrive pas
parce que tu arrives sur le site de
Chepper de France". Tu vois ? Donc
au niveau de la collecte d'argent pour
le financement de votre association
euh tu as récolté des millions ? Pas des
millions ?
Ah non, on a pas récolté des millions.
Non, on a fait une cagnotte il y a 2
mois et elle a elle est à 100000 100000
€. Euh tu vois là nous en en frais de
déplacement depuis l'arrestation de
Paul, on en est à 35000 €.
Tu vois,
tu voyages en seconde classe ? Ah
oui ouais, j'ai été upgradé
lors de mon dernier passage mais ça n'a
pas des
Non même pas. C'est parce que il y a eu
l'avion était sur bouqué ou je sais pas
quoi et du coup ils nous ont upgradé.
D'ailleurs, j'ai posé la question, je
dis pourquoi je suis upgradé ? Non mais
si ça vous plaît pas, on vous non très
bien, ça me va très bien. Mais non, tu
vois c'est c'est vrai que ça coûte très
cher et finalement si on a eu un peu
plus de don que d'habitude quand même.
Le Z Event non ? Ah le Z Event ça a été
bah ouais on a touché 2,4 millions. Donc
c'est bah c'est quasiment notre budget
annuel en 3 jours.
Ça a été partagé entre quatre
associations.
Et d'ailleurs pour pour l'anecdote parmi
les quatre associations, il y avait donc
il y avait six chapurs de France. Il y
avait la WWF, la LPO et six Cleaners. La
LPO, tu vois ce que c'est la ligue pour
la protection des oiseaux
et bou.
Voilà. Et en fait pour te dire l'idée
que les gens ont enfin ils pensent que
si je sais pas c'est énorme et qu'on a
tellement de fric parce qu' nous disent
j'ai lu dans les commentaires mais
pourquoi si chez France et dans ce truc
là ils ont pas besoin d'argent encore la
LPO je comprends mais pas si chez port
France
ils ont besoin d'argent ils sont même
pas venus avec un site de pas nous
offrir
en plus tu vois on est radin en plus non
mais c'est là que tu vois en fait les si
chez Portefance c'est 3 millions d'euros
la LPO c'est 50 millions d'euros tu vois
sauf que les gens ils ont l'impression
que voilà mais parce que on a il y a des
bateaux il y a des images donc les gens
pensent que voilà qu'on a qu'on a
beaucoup d'argent. Après, c'est vrai que
il y a on a fait plus de ventes de
merchandising depuis l'arrestation de
Paul, mais ce que je sais c'est que
c'est que voilà, c'est que tous ceux qui
ont trahi Paul et qui l'ont qui l'ont
évincé, ils ont aussi eu beaucoup plus
de soutien alors que voilà puis nous on
en fera bon usage en tout cas.
Est-ce que tu as peur de la surveillance
? Est-ce que tu as l'impression d'être
écouté ? Est-ce que tu as l'impression
d'être surveillé, d'être pisté ? Est-ce
que
je suis pas J'ai pas peur de la
surveillance parce que en fait
tu communiques en chiffré avec tes
copains.
Même pas.
Mais en fait on fait rien d'illégal, tu
vois.
On fait rien d'illégal et on est hyper
transparent en réalité. Et toutes les
campagnes qu'on fait, on les fait au
grand jour, tu vois. Alors on est poil à
gratter. Tu vois quand on prend des des
dauphins en mer et qu'on vient les
exposer devant la tour Effel ou devant
le Parlement européen ou devant
l'Assemblée nationalein. Mort
mort évidemment. Ouais. Ouais. Non,
sinon c'est et que bah d'ailleurs tu
sais qu'on on a eu on a eu des gardes à
vue pour ça parce que c'est interdit.
Bah ouais. Espèce protégé. Tu as pas le
droit en fait de Sauf que on le fait
pourquoi ? Bah parce que tu as 10000
dauphins qui sont tués chaque année dans
les engins de pêche et que personne voit
rien, personne dit rien. Quand
vous êtes en garde à vue parce que les
flics qui vous ont attrapé, ils vous
regardent c'est bien continuer mais on
est obligé de faire notre boulot. Alors,
il y a il y a il y a de ça. On a eu pas
mal de ça pour l'Assemblée nationale.
L'Assemblée nationale, quand on on a été
on a été ils nous ont collé une amende
et cetera qu'on a pas payé. Mais et il y
en a clairement qui nous disaient
"Putain, mais moi je je fais pas ce
métier là de flic pour coller des
amendes, tu vois." Il voyait les quatre
dauphins là.
Mais il faut que ça change quoi. C'est
et euh et après ouais, il voulait nous
faire un dans d'autres cas un rappel à
loi à la loi en fait parce que bah tu as
transporté un dauphin espèce protégée.
Donc moi je disais aux équipes en fait
on signe pas de rappel à la loi. La loi
on la connaît très bien. Notre objectif
c'est que la loi elle soit justement
respectée. Espèce protégée euh respecté
sur protégé sur le papier. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour pour vraiment les
protéger ? Et là où on s'est rendu
compte que c'était super important de
faire ça, c'est que quand on a exposé
les cadavres de dauphins, on se rend
compte à quel point les gens en fait ne
savaient même pas qu'on avait des
dauphins en France.
Enfin, c'est lunaire.
On a des foques aussi.
On a des foces, de plus en plus de foc
mais mais beaucoup moins que ce que
c'était avant. Et tu as déjà des
pêcheurs qui commencent à dire "Ah bah
attends, ils bouffent trop de poissons,
il faut les retirer de la liste
d'espèces protégées." Parce que voilà,
parce que on se dit on se dit pas que
c'est que c'est nous qui pêchons trop de
poisson, on se dit que c'est les fous
qui qui en pêchent trop. Alors que tu as
toute la colonie de FOC là qui euh qui
mange euh qui mange bah l'équivalent de
d'un coup de filet d'un des d'un des
chalutiers usine euh qu'on qu'on chope
au large de la Manche chaque hiver.
Quel regarde tu portes sur la politique
intérieure française ? Euh son ministre
de l'écologie, de la transition
énergétique verte verte et que tout va
bien se passer dans le futur. Quel
regard tu portes sur eux ? Tu penses que
c'est ils essayent, ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent avec les moyens qu'ils peuvent
dont ils ont dont ils disposent ou tu
penses que c'est simplement de la part ?
Bah
je pense que ça dépend
ça dépend des individus en terme de
conviction mais très clairement en terme
de pouvoir, c'est très très limité. Euh
si je dois comparer par exemple la
ministre de la mer qu'on a eu avant
Hervé Berville qui était Annique
Gérardin qui est une fille de pêcheur de
Saint-Pierre et Miclon qui nous
détestait viscéralement, qui détestait
Paul Watson parce que la chasse au fo
enfin elle ne nous pardonne pas d'avoir
lutté contre la chasse au fo et on avait
affaire à cette ministre là qui nous
disait en fait à cause des ONG les FOC
pulent dans le Saint-Laurent. Le FOC est
une espèce prédatrice qui ne peut pas
puler. Enfin c'est biologiquement
impossible. Et je trouvais ça délirant
d'avoir la ministre de la merde, la 2e
puissance maritime mondiale qui qui
tiennent un discours aussi aberrant, tu
vois. Donc on partait très très loin
avec elle. Euh le ministre qui lui a euh
succédé, c'est Hervé Berville
euh avec lequel on avait euh beaucoup
plus de contact euh qui je pense euh
était de meilleure volonté mais qui euh
était aussi très très limité euh dans ce
qu'il pouvait faire. et euh sur la
question des captures de dauphin euh bah
à plutôt euh à plutôt euh plaidé du côté
euh du côté pêcheur. J'ai
la pêche au thon.
La pêche au thon.
Ils sont au courant que la surpêche des
tons c'est compliqué, ils en parlent
avec vous pas du tout.
Bah alors, tu parles de la pêche du ton
rouge ou la pêche du ton rouge ? Bah
pour le coup, nous on a fait pas mal de
campagnes là-dessus, notamment en 2010.
Moi, j'ai géré la campagne où on a
libéré 800 ton rouges en Méditerranée,
en Libye, euh à l'époque où euh bah le
ton rouge a a frôer les les
l'effondrement, l'extinction. Si tu
veux, tu avais un un quota euh
scientifique de 7000 7000 tonnes. Euh tu
avais 13000 tonnes euh qui était accordé
par les États et puis tu montais à 40000
tonnes en fait de péché. Encore une
fois, tu vois, on parle en tonne, hein.
Et donc euh et donc en fait, le ton
rouge a failli disparaître à cause de
ça. Euhh, il y a eu un renforcement des
contrôles. Donc là, la population de ton
rouge euh c'est à peu près rétabli mais
bon, tu sens bien que ils sont tous au
taquet parce que c'est un poisson qui
vaut tellement cher, tu sais, ça atteint
des prix délirants. Tu as une femelle
ton rouge qui a été vendue plus d'un
million euh au Japon.
Et ce que les gens ne font pas comme
connexion, c'est que tu penses au ton
rouge mais tu penses pas à tout ce qu'il
y a autour. Et en fait là en ce moment,
on est sur une grosse campagne qu'on a
commencé cette année qui va durer 5 mois
tous les ans pour les orques. Je sais
pas si tu as entendu parler des orqus de
Gibraltar. En fait, celle qui alors
ouais
celle qui chahut un petit peu les
bateaux.
C'est des c'est des orques Shepard.
C'est ça.
C'est des orques. C'est des orques
joueuses. Euh le fait est que cette
population d'or en question là c'est 40
individus. Donc elle est en danger
critique d'extinction et elle ne fait
parler d'elle que parce que euh elle
cause des dégâts matériels, tu vois. Et
elle est en danger critique d'extinction
à cause de la surpêche du ton rouge
parce qu'elle ne vit exclusivement que
grâce au ton rouge. Et parce que le ton
rouge s effondré en fait, elles arrivent
même pas à se reproduire. Elles arrivent
pas, les femelles elles arrivent pas à
avoir assez de lait pour avoir des
petits et donc c'est catastrophique.
Revenons au gouvernement français et et
à notre plétor de ministre.
Est-ce je vais te lire une question
d'internet, tu vas comprendre ma
question. Bonsoir et merci pour votre
temps. Comment arrivez-vous à continuer
de lutter en constatant la trajectoire
actuelle ? N'avez-vous pas le sentiment
de pédaler dans la semoule ?
Non, parce que je te dire moi, par
exemple, chaque fois qu'on est qu'on est
sur des plages de Mayotte et qu'on sauve
des tortues qui auraient été massacrés à
la machette si on avait pas été là,
chaque fois que justement on patrouille
dans les trois de Gibraltar et qu'on
entend qu'en fait les pêcheurs qui
balancentaient des explosifs sur les
orqus et ben ils font attention parce
qu'ils savent qu'on est là. Euh chaque
fois que ben on est aux îles ferroé et
que ben malheureusement on peut pas
sauver les glob parce que nos bateaux
sont interdits.
Les globicéphales pardon parce que le
Danemark nous envoie ses frégates
militaires mais tu vois que je fais un
live sur le massacre en question et que
il y a des milliers de personnes qui se
rendent compte ou qui apprennent ce qui
se passe et que bah on travaille à faire
bouger les lignes même si c'est une
campagne qui est particulièrement
frustrante. Euh tout ça ça fait
continuer et puis surtout euh bah si
j'arrête si j'arrête je fais quoi ? Je
trouve qu'on peut pas se payer le luxe
d'être désespéré aujourd'hui.
C'est c'est pas possible. Et surtout, il
y a un truc que j'ai appris,
c'est que je ne suis responsable que de
ce que je fais. Je ne suis pas
responsable de ce qu'il advient du
monde. C'estd que j'ai eu pendant très
longtemps justement cette charge mentale
et le poids de la culpabilité qui fait
que tu t'arrêtes jamais parce que ah
si tu t'arrêtes un jour, tu
prends un déof et le monde il est en
train de partir en vrai et toi tu es en
déof, tu vois. Et c'est en fait c'est
intenable.
Et c'est ce que j'ai ce que j'ai appris,
ce que j'ai compris, c'est que c'est pas
la culpabilité qui peut me faire
avancer, mais c'est le sens des
responsabilités. Et je ne suis pas
responsable de ce qu' devient du monde,
mais je suis responsable de ce que moi
je fais. Et ce que je veux surtout, ce
qui est très important pour moi, c'est
que le jour où je vais me retourner sur
ma vie, je vais me dire "Bah moi, j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu en fait."
Et tu peux te regarder dans la glace
chaque matin.
Exactement.
L'usine à gaz européenne, ça vous aide ?
Ça vous aide pas, ça t'aide ? Ça t'aide
pas ? Comment ça se passe ?
Euh
il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients en fait. Euh ça dépend des
sujets. Par exemple, tu vois sur les sur
les captures de dauphin et ben c'est
l'Europe qui va mettre un peu la
pression à la France pour mettre en
place les mesures parce qu'on a des
obligations au niveau européen. Et dans
le même temps et dans le même temps, tu
vas voir aussi bah une Europe qui
t'empêche aussi de bah de faire ce que
tu veux. Euh donc ça dépend des cas en
fait, ça dépend vraiment des des
ça dépend des cas. Les accords européen
de pêche par exemple avec l'Afrique,
c'est une catastrophe. Euh tu vois,
c'est une forme de néo néocolonialisme.
Euh
donc en fonction des sujets, tu vois sur
l'éolien par exemple, l'éolien, bah
pareil, c'est l'Europe qui nous impose
un quota d'éolienne en mer qui est
intenable, complètement intenable et qui
à côté de ça nous dit il faut zéro
perten de biodiversité.
zéro perten de biodiversité. On est
censé coller des éoliennes tout au long
de la côte en plein cœur des air marines
protégées avec des hachoirs qui vont et
et enfin c'est schizophrène, tu vois. En
fait,
les oiseaux, ils tombent dans l'eau, tu
les vois pas, tu peux pas les compter.
Mais tu sais que en fait effectivement
il y a ça, mais le pire c'est même pas
ça. Le pire c'est la perte d'habitat.
C'estàd que ils nous foutent des
éoliennes qui vont en fait faire que les
les oiseaux évitent les zones. Sauf
qu'en fait c'est sur des zones de
d'inidification ou des couloirs de
migration qui et en fait la première
perte la première cause de
l'effondrement de la biodive c'est la
perte de l'habitat. Et en fait toutes
ces éoliennes mis bout à bout en fait
elles font que c'est le parcours du
combattant pour les oiseaux mais aussi
pour les mammifères marins et pour tout.
Et tu as aussi les câbles électriques
sous-marins avec 220000 V qui passent
sous le plancher océanique avec des
conséquences catastrophiques pour
certaines espèces. Puis ça c'est même
pas c'est même pas pris en compte.
Question internet. le constat. OK, on
est tous d'accord. Maintenant, les
solutions, c'est quoi ?
Et ben, en fait, quand on me dit euh
c'est quoi les solutions, euh
moi je veux dire ça commence par changer
de regard en fait. Euh
tu vois le
il y a des problèmes de tous les côtés,
tu sais même pas par les par lequel les
prendre. Euh et moi je pense que changer
de regard déjà sur notre lien à l'océan
et sur notre pouvoir de faire les choses
euh sur le fait qu'on n pas isolé les
uns des autres, sur le fait qu'on peut
contribuer chacun euh ça commence par ça
et puis surtout se reconnecter en fait
parce que revoir aussi le sens des
priorités,
tu vois, c'est j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
solution magique. Je dirais il y a il y
a un truc quand même un truc qui est
hyper efficace.
Arrêtez de manger de la viande.
Arrêtez de manger des animaux. Ça c'est
la portée de n'importe qui. C'est la
portée de tout le monde. C'est un truc
que tu fais.
Manger le moins possible.
En manger le moins possible.
Soutenons les éleveurs qui font bien
leur boulot. Alors moi, je soutiens pas
Moi, je soutiens personne euh à ce
niveau-là, mais euh mais j'invite les
gens à se à vraiment se poser la
question là-dessus, à ne pas euh à ne
pas beauté en touche et à faire la part
des choses, à peser le pour et le
contre. Est-ce que finalement euh
est-ce que ça vaut le coup ?
Le jambon pas gras quand même.
Tu parles à une ancienne viande, donc si
on parle de goût, moi je vais pas te
dire de toute façon je comprends pas.
Non, je comprends. J'adorais la viande.
Je mangeais de la viande midi et soir.
C'est juste qu'à un moment donné,
midi et soir,
c'est mauvais pour la santé. Mais je te
dis fut une époque, c'est mangé des
sushis, j'ai mangé des Big Mac au McDo.
Voilà, j'ai connu tout ça, tu vois.
C'est juste qu' à un moment donné je me
dis en fait
ce que ça implique comme souffrance
auquel je n'ai pas envie de participer,
le plaisir gustatif que ça me donne,
j'ai fait la part des choses. Voilà. Et
je me suis dit simplement euh pour moi
c'est important en fait l'équité, la
justice et cetera. Je sais que moi je ne
pourrais pas infliger ces
souffrances-là. Donc si je le fais c'est
que je suis hypocrite, c'est que je ne
suis pas la personne que je crois être.
Donc en fait je ferme ma gueule si je
continue à en manger. Ou alors je suis
vraiment celle que je dois être et ce
que je crois être. Et je mets mes actes
en adéquation avec mes convictions et
j'arrête d'en manger. Donc après ça a
été un choix personnel.
Question internet qui n'est pas une
question, c'est un commentaire. C'est
dommage de l'avoir interrompu quand elle
parlait de ce qu'elle pensait de Greta
Thonberg.
Ça me semble important. Greta Tonberg.
Qu'est-ce que je pense de Greta Thberg ?
H
ben tu vois ce que ça m'inspire. Non
non, c'est euh je sais pas euh
les marches pour le climat, ça a jamais
été un truc qui m'a qui m'a fait bouger
en fait. Je pense que c'était bien d'en
faire parce que ça permettait aussi de
se rendre compte que c'est pas ça qui va
faire bouger les lignes.
Euh
et moi, j'ai jamais été marché pour le
climat, honnêtement. Euh peut-être parce
que c'est parce que je fais autre chose,
hein. Peut-être que si j'étais pas du
tout impliquée, bah j'irais faire ma
marche et
mais c'est pas ça qui me en tout cas moi
c'est c'est pas ça qui m'inspire.
Question internet, elle porte des
bijoux. Est-elle consciente de l'impact
écologique du secteur minier ?
Euh oui, complètement. Euh tout comme je
suis consciente de l'impact écologique
euh de la fabrication des jeans, euh du
téléphone portable, euh de l'ordinateur,
du séchoir à chev
euh de voilà l'électricité qui est
probablement nucléaire. Euh moi je suis
pas euh je suis pas parfaite et je pense
qu'on on ne l'est pas et qu'à partir du
moment où on a un certificat de
naissance, on a une empreinte, euh le
fait est que il s'agit de euh d'en avoir
conscience et de la minimiser.
Donc euh
est-ce que tu es pour un pass carbone ?
Est-ce que chacun devrait avoir un pass
avec le nombre de kilos de biloge qui
devrait manger, le nombre de voyages en
avion, le nombre de transport, s'il
roule au gasoil, pas au gasoil, s'il
chouffe au fiou, pas au fou.
Oh là là ! Non non, je pense que ça
serait infernal. Honnêtement,
c'est facile à implémenter avec un peu
d'intelligence artificielle, une
surveillance de la carte,
avec un petit QR code.
On a eu déjà l'expérience. Euh
non, moi j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de
vivre dans ce monde là en fait. Euh j'ai
plutôt envie d'être dans un monde où euh
où on est euh où on est on apprend à
vivre en harmonie avec euh avec le
milieu qui nous entoure, avec les autres
espèces et avec euh et avec nos
nos compatriotes.
C'est euh
un monde de fliquage en fait. Je pense
pas que ce soit
que ce soit pertinent
et c'est peut-être une solution. Non.
Quoi donc ? le fliquage.
H tu vois le problème en mer par exemple
c'est justement qu'il y a pas de police
are mer c'est que il y a des règles, il
y a des lois mais il y a personne pour
les faire respecter. Donc tu vois bien
que il y a besoin aussi. Euh
il y a des satellites pourtant.
Ouais, il y a des satellites mais c'est
pas suffisant. Et puis euh en fait, tu
as des millions de bateaux hein qui qui
prennent la mer tous les jours. Euh
c'est euh si tu as pas les moyens après
euh de faire les contrôles et les
arrestations euh euh ça sert à rien.
Donc tu as une meilleure vision mais tu
as pas pour autant au bout euh des euh
des des vrais résultats. Euh je suis pas
sûr que les gens respecteraient vraiment
les limitations de vitesse si tu avais
pas si tu avais pas bah un code de la
route avec des limitations de vitesse
avec des amendes à la clé. Euh je suis
pas pour les amendes he mais avec des
amendes
Ouais. Non mais en fait c'est je pense
qu'il y a un équilibre à trouver entre
euh entre la responsabilisation et puis
en même temps euh
et en même temps un minimum de coerition
parce que sinon euh sinon ça marche pas.
question internet qui est très très
longue. Donc on va essayer de
synthétiser.
Que pensez-vous du mode d'action direct
des plus impactantes consistant à
l'occupation physique des lieux tels que
sont les zones à défendre, les ADES
actuellement des exactions contre les
militants écologistes torturés par des
cadres de la lutte. Oh là là !
[Musique]
Qu'est-ce que je pense des consistant ?
les ades. Est-ce que
la résistance passive, la greffe de la
fin, ça sert à quelque chose ?
S'enchaîner, monter en haut des arbres ?
Moi, je pense que il faut une
multiplicité d'approche euh et que dans
certains cas
ça peut être utile. Euh l'idée c'est de
braquer les projecteurs, c'est de faire
parler, c'est de faire bouger les lignes
euh et puis finalement les moyens qui
nous sont qui nous sont laissés sont
assez restreints. Tu vois, l'État a
quand même le monopole de la violence
légitime
de la violence. Légitime. Ouais. Donc
voilà, tout ce qui est désobéissance
civile,
Zade pour une cause juste euh pour moi
éthiquement ça se justifie.
Tu avais été à Notrad des Landes ?
Non.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses que maintenant
certains groupes écologistes se
militarisent, utilisent un champ lexical
militaire ? Ils ont des cibles, ils ont
des targets, ils ont des vecteurs.
Pour l'instant, ça reste dans le champ
lexical.
Non, ça ça reste aussi dans le mode
opératoire en terme de communication, en
terme de je veux pas dire d'armement
mais de comment ralentir
pour l'instant pour l'instant c'est
surtout les écologistes qui se font tuer
plutôt que l'inverse
partout dans les forêts, au Brésil, à
côté des mines,
particulièrement effectivement en
Amérique du Sud. Euh mais euh je pense
que au fur et à mesure de euh
l'effondrement euh qui arrivent euh on
va aller vers euh des mouvements
justement de plus en plus violents.
C'est c'est inéluctable. Donc euh est-ce
que
c'est la solution ?
Je dis pas que c'est la solution. Je dis
pas que c'est ce que je souhaite, je dis
que c'est inéluctable euh parce que euh
il y aura rien de pire en fait qu'un
effondrement euh qu'un effondrement des
des écosystèmes.
Euh ça c'est la pire des guerres qui
soit et donc forcément ça va être très
très violent. Donc le but justement
c'est de c'est d'éviter ça mais on
l'évitera que si que si on trouve
d'autres solutions en amont évite le
pire.
Tu crois qu'on va l'éviter ? C'est
difficile de faire un pronostic
honnêtement. Euh
je je sais pas tu vois quand on me
demande "Est-ce que tu es optimiste ou
est-ce que tu es pessimiste Euh je je me
déconnecte de ça
parce que
en fonction des jours en fait ma réponse
serait différente.
Euh moi je pense que ce qui est
important c'est euh c'est de faire ce
qu'on croit être juste aujourd'hui.
Etth on verra de quoi sera fait demain.
Tu vois, je suis maman et donc et donc
forcément, j'y pense encore plus
qu'avant de l'être. Euh le monde qu'on
laisse à nos enfants. Et c'est vrai que
ça peut paraître effrayant. Raison de
plus pour se battre aujourd'hui.
Tu es maman depuis combien de temps ?
Bientôt 8 ans.
Tu t'es posé la question avant de faire
un Bien sûr. Oui, je me suis posé la
question. Je me suis dit déjà bon on est
8 milliards, moi j'ai pas besoin de
rajouter ma petite contribution.
Mais euh
mais je reprends euh un un
positionnement qu' Paul à ce sujet,
c'est que ils disent souvent que en fait
les gens qui se posent des questions qui
hésitent à faire des enfants parce
qu'ils sont conscients de l'état du
monde sont justement ceux qui devraient
en avoir, tu vois. Donc parce que on
transmet aussi certaines valeurs.
Moi ma fille je l'éduque dans le respect
du vivant, dans le respect d'autrui.
Mange de la viande.
Ah non non.
Et c'est pas c'est pas néfaste à son
développement.
Et ben écoute, si tu la voyais, tu me
croirais sur parole. Mais non, enfin le
mythe de l'enfant carencé parce qu'il
mange pas d'animaux.
Enfin, en France, on est on est encore
un peu en retard par rapport à ça, mais
non. Euh euh ma fille, elle est je
touche du bois en pleine santé. Euh elle
a jamais mangé d'animal de sa vie. euh à
la cantine en maternelle, un jour, ils
l'ont obligé à manger de la viande et
elle est revenue en pleurant disant
qu'elle voulait plus aller à la cantine.
Donc, il a fallu avoir une discussion
avec la directrice qui nous a dit euh
"Ah non, mais bon, c'est pas pour des
raisons de santé, c'est pas pour des
raisons de religion, donc on peut pas
non plus s'adapter à tout le monde."
Donc son père lui a expliqué "Oui, mais
c'est pour des raisons éthiques. La
petite, elle ne veut pas manger
d'animaux parce que elle aime les
animaux. On ne l'oblige pas à ne pas en
manger. Elle elle a compris, si tu
veux."
Euh et d'ailleurs et c'est ça me
rappelle une scène qu'il y a eu il y a
pas longtemps. J'ai une amie qui
commande du cochon euh mais c'était dans
des trucs panés ça ça donnait envie avec
du fromage. Et donc ma fille me dit
"J'en veux." Je dis "Mais tu sais que
c'est du cochon ?" Parce queelle quand
elle voit
cochon mort.
Oui
en plus.
Oui. Bon ouais c'était même pas un
cochon vivant. Mais non parce que quand
elle voit passer les cochons vivants
dans les camions qui vont à l'abattoir,
elle me dit "Maman, pourquoi tu les
sauves pas ?"
Je dis "Ben je suis désolée chérie, je
peux pas, je peux pas." Et donc elle me
dit "Je veux en manger." Je dis "Tu sais
ce que c'est ?" Tu sais les cochons que
tu vois dans le dans les camions, c'est
ça. Donc si tu veux en manger, euh
vas-y, mais la prochaine fois, tu me
diras pas "Maman, on va sauver les
cochons".
Mais ça pourrait être du cochon bien
élevé, tranquille, avec un petit peu un
petit massage. Euh,
alors bah c'est très très improbable
hein, parce que quand même en terme de
en terme de alors j'ai pas les chiffres
exacts, mais je crois qu'on a plus de 95
% de cochon. Euh enfin c'est assez
catastrophique. Et puis
les barreaux pour sécréter les
endorphines pour apaer apaiser leur
c'est inhumain en fait clairement les
les conditions les conditions d'élevage
mais quand bien même ça aurait été un
cochon qui a eu sa belle vie et qui a
été qui a été égorgé alors qu'il avait
rien demandé que qui aurait bien voulu
continuer dit avant. Oui. Ouais. Tu es
peu importe.
Je sais que c'est pas quelque chose
qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle a dont elle a
envie et donc je lui ai laissé le choix.
En fait, je dis "Je te laisse le choix.
Si tu veux en manger, mange-en. Mais ne
fais pas semblant de ne pas savoir ce
que c'est. Tu sais ce que c'est." Elle a
refusé.
Et si elle réclamait un burger d'insecte
?
Ben
un burger de protéine d'insectes,
ben c'est la même chose.
C'est la même chose. Quand elle voit euh
un papillon, une cocinelle, euh bah elle
a pas envie de la bouffer.
Quand tu manges quand tu manges de la
salade et tous les végétaux pour ton
alimentation, est-ce que tu es conscient
que ce que tu manges, si c'est pas bio,
élevé, comme un bon petit maréchier avec
son engrais, avec du fumier, des puré
purin d'orti, la majeure partie des
hydrocarbures.
le fertilisant,
un insecticide
de lumière audessus des pieds de tomate.
C'est c'est tout un système qu'il faut
revoir. Mais tu vois la viande que tu
vas manger, t'inquiète que ce qu'elle a
bouffé, bah ça a utilisé du carburant,
des enfin tout ce que tu es en train de
me citer et des pesticides et compagnie.
Donc c'est tu es juste à un niveau un
niveau supérieur. Alors après ceux qui
ont les moyens d'avoir ben un petit
potager bio, un coin de jardin et de
manger ça, ben tant mieux pour eux. Le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas et que le bio est plus cher que
le conventionnel ce qui est aberrant
puisque tu rajoutes des intrans et ça
coûte moins cher que s'il y en a pas.
Donc
perd aussi dans le bio. Il y a beaucoup
de pertes.
Il
y a il y a des veroles, il y a des
parasites, il y a pas le même rendement.
Ouais. Bah
ça demande plus de de main d'œuvre.
Plus de main d'œuvre. Bah tant mieux. Ça
va créer de l'emploi. J'ai envie de te
dire. Euh c'est pas et puis les fruits,
les légumes sont peut-être moins beaux
mais mais voilà, c'est revenir à quelque
chose qui était complètement naturel
avant.
Est-ce que tu veux rajouter un sujet ou
une question qu'on a pas abordé pendant
cette interview ? Est-ce que tu veux
reparler de Paul ? Est-ce que tu veux
parler d'un autre truc ? Est-ce que tu
veux parler d'Emmanuel Macron ? Est-ce
que tu veux parler de Ursula à l'Europe
? Est-ce que tu veux faire une dédicace
? Est-ce que tu veux aborder un sujet ?
Est-ce que tu veux nous dire ce que tu
as vu le plus beau qui t'a le plus
émerveillé sur un bateau ?
Non. Bah peut-être un un mot sur Paul
peut-être expliquer juste euh
pourquoi il est pourquoi il est inculpé
? Qu'est-ce qui risque ? Bah, c'est ce
qui risque clairement, bah c'est la
c'est les c'est la perpétuité euh dans
des conditions horribles. Euh mais
surtout
c'est 15 ans, mais voilà, il a 74 ans
euh
dans les conditions en plus dans
lesquelles il sera. Bon, euh je pense
que voilà, je veux même pas imaginer ce
scénario parce que moi ça me ça ça me
coupe les gens. Donc j'espère bien qu'on
va qu'on va éviter l'extradition, mais
surtout comprendre
ce qu'il y a derrière cette chasse à
l'homme et ce que ça signifie aussi pour
tous les lanceurs d'alerte, c'est que
Paul Watson, c'est quand même alors
c'est pas c'est pas une star de rock
mais il est pas complètement inconnu non
plus, tu vois. C'est quelqu'un qui a
quand même une certaine notoriété. Il y
a une belle
un épisode de South Park avec lui.
C'est la consécration ultime ça. Il y a
quand même une belle une belle
mobilisation pour lui, tu vois. et on
est sur un dossier
qui est toute petite
qui est qui est toute petite par rapport
à ce que à ce que ça devrait être mais
euh qui est quand même importante par
rapport à ce que ça serait pour
quelqu'un de complètement inconnu, tu
vois, et sur un dossier qui est
complètement fabriqué avec des preuves
délirantes, avec une parodie de justice.
Donc si avec tout ça, on narrive pas à
le sortir de là, euh vraiment c'est
hyper hyper hyper inquiétant comme
message pour l'ensemble des lanceurs
d'alerte et des activistes. Et le Japon
à travers Paul essae aussi d'envoyer un
message à l'ensemble des activistes et
des lanceurs d'alerte. Si vous nous
faites chier, voilà ce qui va vous
arriver. On vous collera au basque. On
vous traquera jusqu'au bout. Tu as
ce qui s'est passé avec Julien Sange.
Comment ça c'est fini ?
Ouais. 14 ans de d'emprisonnement dans
des conditions dramatiques
à l'isolement à la fin. Euh
hm
c'est des exemples, c'est des exemples
qui sont qui sont donnés. Et donc euh
au-delà au-delà de Paul, c'est c'est
vraiment sur tout un mouvement en fait
qu'il s'agit qu'il s'agit de sauver.
Mais moi, je pense que ils font un très
très mauvais calcul parce que s'ils font
de Paul un martyre euh ça suscitera
tellement de je pense de colère, de
sentiments, d'injustice que euh
je pense que ça insufflera quelque chose
de nouveau.
Tu
optimiste ?
Ouais, mais euh
mais vraiment, j'y crois.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Alors
ben
les nouvelles promesses des psychotropes
de Michael Polan, c'est sur c'est sur
les psychédéliques.
Ah, tu t'attendais pas à ça ?
C'est non mais c'est un bouquin assez
incroyable sur justement les
psychédéliques, le LSD, la psylocibine,
la guerre contre les drogues qu'a fait
Nixon aux États-Unis justement à travers
le mouvement IPI qui a été catalogué par
rapport à ça. Mais moi, je parlais de
connexion et cetera et en fait des des
substances qui ouvrent la conscience et
qui reconnectent en fait au tout et la
nature. Tu vois ceux qui prenaient par
exemple du LSD ou de la psyciibine ne
voulaient sur était antiguerre au
Vietnam. Ils étaient en communion avec
la nature. Alors du coup, ils ont été
étiquetés hein. Voilà, Baba, cool et
cetera. Ça été une façon aussi de
complètement les conspirationnistes
n'existait pas encore à l'époque.
Voilà. Mais sinon, ils y auraient eu
droit de les décrédibiliser.
Aujourd'hui, tu as la recherche
notamment aux États-Unis, mais pas que
aussi en Suisse, en Angleterre qui
reprend notamment dans les soins
palliatifs chez les les cancers les
cancérons en phase terminale,
les gens à pulsion suicidaire pour qui
en fait bah big pharma ne peut plus rien
faire, c'est-à-dire que les
antidépresseurs ne fonctionnent plus et
cetera et qui se rendent compte qu'en
fait avec la psycipline,
ils obtiennent des résultats qui sont
absolument incroyables, notamment sur la
notion de la peur de mourir, sur le sens
de la vie, des choses qui sont
absolument
époustoufflantes et je pense qu'il y a
un vrai sujet par rapport à ça. C'est
strictement interdit en France
mais je trouve que c'est vraiment un
sujet qui vaut la peine d'être creusé.
Et tu te rends comptes aussi quand tu
quand tu vois un peu les études qui sont
sorties mais des plus grandes
universités hein aux États-Unis et en
Angleterre sur la notion justement de
liberté que ça inculque et de citoyens
en fait libre de penser par eux-mêmes
euh qui se reconnectent à des choses
essentielles à travers justement des
substances psychédéliques qui sont
absolument incroyables à à à pratiquer
dans des contextes qui sont très
encadrés euh et légaux
Euh voilà. Donc bon, encore une fois, en
France, ça n'est pas normal, ça n'est
pas légal. Mais voilà, je c'est un très
bon bouquin. Un deuxè
euh un deuxè je dirais euh Sapiens de
Harari euh
parce que j'ai trouvé ça intéressant en
fait
la façon dont il explique justement ce
qui fait la particularité
de l'espèce humaine sur la façon dont on
raconte des récits et dont on a
justement remplacé le réel par
l'imaginaire.
et qui est à la base finalement de
beaucoup de nos de nos problèmes qui a
fait aussi que on a pu en fait entre
guillemets dominer le monde. C'estàd que
tu as des millions de personnes qui ne
se connaissent pas qui vont lutter
ensemble
pour un dieu, pour un drapeau, pour tu
vois et
pour de la tune surtout hein.
Oui aussi. Mais la tune c'est un
imaginaire
pour un dieu pour un dieu Jérusalem
route de commerce. Non, mais c'est pour
un imaginaire, quel qu'il soit, tu vois.
Euh et et je trouve ça je trouve ça
assez euh assez fascinant. Tu
connais le le poème le renoncement de
Saint-Pierre ?
Non.
La fin ça termine par "Oui, je sortirai
de ce monde où l'action n'est pas sœur
du rêve."
Bon, avant, il y avait un petit passage
avec le bouclier le glève, mais
et un troisème bouquin,
un troisème, la soif de l'essentiel.
C'est un petit bouquin absolument
magique qui coûte 3,50 € que tu mets
dans la poche qui est un concentré de
spiritualité, de philosophie, de vérité,
de fulgurance.
C'est un auteur iranien dont j'arrive
jamais à me souvenir du nom, mais la
soif de l'essentiel vraiment je le
recommande à tout le monde.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Oui. Alors, ben j'ai écrit un article
qui s'appelle lettre à ma jeune âme
révoltée. C'est la lettre que je m'écris
à moi quand j'avais 18 ans. Euh
le conseil ça serait euh ce serait
d'écouter votre petite voix euh et de
n'écouter quel finalement quels que
soient les signaux qu'on peut avoir de
l'extérieur.
Parce que quand on l'écoute, il y a un
alignement des étoiles qui fait que vous
allez sur le bon chemin. Euh c'est
la vie est pleine de surprise mais il
faut oser. Il faut oser. Il faut sortir
du
sa zone de confort
complètement.
Lamia Lali. Merci.
Merci à toi.
[Musique]